welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast a new book
was recently released about the
carnivore diet and while we don't review
the book itself we do provide a really
nice review of the books cover in
today's episode we also review a
documentary called the game changers
this is a new documentary about
plant-based diets that has caused a lot
of strong opinions in the fitness
industry and we have some opinions of
our own on the training side of things
greg has a research roundup segment for
us and in that segment he reviews three
recent studies about foam rolling the
relationship between capillary density
and muscle growth and finally the
relationship between resistance training
and your risk of death finally we've got
an excellent interview with Michael hall
from examine calm and he tells us
everything we could possibly want to
know about ketogenic diets as always
thank you for listening and we hope you
enjoy the episode
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
stronger by science podcast this is your
host Eric Trexler and today we've got to
treat a special temporary guest host
named Greg knuckles hey think thanks for
inviting me on this is a honor and a
privilege I'm sure you're gonna do a
great job before we get into our feats
of strength I've got a little segment
here is it is this a read of the week do
you think Greg that seems strong I would
say it's it's a recommended against read
of the week if that if that's a thing
yeah so Greg brought this to my
attention the other day and hard as I
try I just can't get it out of my mind
it's the single greatest piece of
graphic design in human history yeah so
the book recently got released it was
called our carnivore diet how to cure
depression and disease with meat only
and on the book's cover and in the the
amazon link for the book the two authors
are listed as Jordan and Mikaela
Peterson Jordan's listed as first author
there yeah I just noticed that my eyes
were stuck but by extension Michaela is
listed as senior author correct yeah
interesting yeah I hadn't even gotten to
the the author line because my eyes were
focused on her so turns out they after
this came out people were talking about
it they said nope that that is not us it
turns out somebody basically just
compiled a bunch of their transcripts
and blog posts and stuff stapled it
together through a cover on it and said
hey here's a book from them and just
started selling it so Amazon eventually
did take the book down so you can last I
checked you can no longer buy it on
Amazon because it incorrectly attributed
authorship to Jordan and Michaela
Peterson they wrote all the content in
it but they did not put it together they
did not come up with the title and they
did not sell it or unfortunately they
are not able to take credit for the
incredible
cover art that is really a huge step
forward for graphic design I'm gonna do
my best to describe this and then Greg
you go ahead and jump in and catch
anything I missed so they are on a beach
Michaela is inexplicably magnified two
to threefold larger than Jordan but they
appear to both be on the same Beach it's
not like it's not like it's two separate
images I mean and so Nick Michaela don't
know so I mean it is clearly
photoshopped because you can look at the
way that the light is hitting both of
them and it's quite different like so I
mean slightly from Mikayla's right in
Jordan's left which is impossible given
how they're standing yes absolutely that
is clearly photoshopped but what I'm
suggesting is it seems like the attempt
was to make it look like they were on
the same Beach like in the same image
and the perspectives and the sizing and
the shadows they're just it's it's just
absolute chaos
Michaela looks like she's on a beach you
know she's wearing a bikini
Jordan is wearing a colorful beach towel
and looking down and there's just a lot
going on in the image and it's worth
noting that for some reason they chose
the font that is essentially exclusively
reserved for like thriller like murder
mystery novels so I think they used
three different fonts on the title which
I don't think is is typographical
best-practice oh man
and Jordan very hypocritically is not
standing up straight with his shoulders
back which is just abominable to me yeah
that's rule number one right I think so
yeah so so me being a you know a bit of
a nutrition buff myself I was curious as
to the subtitle which is how to cure
depression and disease with meat only
now that's a big claim I'm gonna be
completely transparent I have not yet
read the book
I'm sure there's sufficient evidence
within there to justify the claim well
calling it a book is a bit of a stretch
right isn't it just like a collection of
curated blog posts yeah but it's bound
together sure so we're gonna I'm gonna
call that a book now what kind of
evidence would you need to justify such
a huge claim I would like to see
documentation of how faster children are
now if you were to if you were to give
me confirm and and you can't do like a
handheld stopwatch I went late confirmed
[Laughter]
electronically timed 100-meter and
200-meter data if you don't if if you
don't know what we're talking about
right well just just ask Elaine Norton
about his his Twitter spat with Makayla
Peterson and how she suggested they
settle it yeah so basically in their
discussion of whether or not the
carnivore diet was the one and only true
diet she said let's do this the most
rigorous way we can think our children
should race and if my if my carnivore
children are faster than your omnivore
children then I believe we know all we
need to know so I'm again I I haven't
read it I am NOT making a claim about
what's between those covers but I assume
there are volumes of longitudinal
running times and I think that would be
sufficient evidence okay so great
let's rapidly move on to anything else
that exists such as feats of strength
all righty
so starting with two somewhat
unconventional feats more just feats of
athletic performance so as I'm sure most
of you know but some of you may not know
if you're just only focused on the
strength world both
marathon World Records recently fell so
Elliott kept show game ran one hour 59
minutes 40 seconds that's not an
official world record because it wasn't
done in an open race he had people
handing him water instead of having to
like go to a table and grab water like
there's some there are a lot of people
trying to discredit it but I mean he ran
26.2 miles in under two hours which is
absolutely outrageous and I think a lot
of the the arguments people are putting
forth against it at least to my ears
come across as like pretty facile so you
know they say oh he's wearing better
shoes it's like dude technology has
improved in every sport in existence
Usain Bolt wasn't running with spikes on
a cinder track the same way Jesse Owens
was so I mean yeah technology's gotten
better still no one else has run that in
two hours he had Pacers which helped
break the wind for him which isn't so
that's not a strategy used in marathon
all that often but like it could be
that's something that's done in Road
Cycling all the time so people are like
oh he had Pacers you know people to
break the wind for him whatever he still
ran a marathon in under two hours I
figure at some point we'll see someone
do it in a normal sanctioned race as far
as I see it he's the one that broke the
barrier one of the most impressive
things I've ever seen so that happened
and then yeah I mean I I was at a
presentation by Andrew Jones a while
back he's a big-time cardiovascular guys
done a lot of beetroot juice research
over in the UK and he was in charge of
Nikes breaking 2 project and that it was
a big project funded by Nike to try to
make make it happen the first sub two
hour marathon and his presentation was
about all of the new
and intricacies of what their approach
was the calculations they used about
oxygen transport and exercise efficiency
to see if it was even doable if they
could even make the numbers work
realistically and I saw that
presentation very shortly I believe
after the failed attempt and to see it
happen like this you know I'm one of
those people who I'm not an endurance
endurance running purist by any means
obviously it'll be a it'll be cool to
see it done under more typical racing
conditions in like a sanctioned marathon
event but in any case it's just wildly
fascinating and very very very cool know
for sure and I mean the the thing about
Kip show game is he's obviously an
incredible athlete I think pretty much
indisputably the best marathon runner
ever I think something a lot of people
don't realize is he could have
potentially been even better so Kip Cho
gaze 34 distance like long distance
athletes tend to age better than
strength athletes do so for example if
you're a weightlifter and you're 30
typically you are considerably over the
hill by that point so it's not as steep
of a fall-off for endurance athletes but
they do still tend to be their best kind
of in the neighborhood of 30 years old
so like 34 you wouldn't expect a big
drop-off that is still slightly over the
hill by marathoners standards I guess
and so a thing to note about Kip show
gave is you know he's incredible has the
fastest marathon time in a sanctioned
race as well like 201 38 give or take
but he didn't turn to marathon running
until I believe 2013 give or take so
prior to that he ran the 5k in the 10k
and was good but not like you know not
like runaway best in the world and so he
switched to half marathons in 2012
in its 2019 so he would have been 27
already and then switched to marathons
in 2013 so I mean obviously like there's
going to be carryover from being a elite
10k runner to being a half marathon and
marathon runner but it's not like this
is something he's trained for his entire
life if he started chipping away at the
marathon record when he was 18 who knows
what he could have run when he was like
28 if that's when he was peaking in the
marathon instead of just getting into
the sport so absolutely incredible
athlete and you know one of these days
there's gonna come someone else who is
just as talented as him and you know
we'll do it in a race or who knows he
may he may do it in their sanctioned
marathon as well
can I share an interesting marathon
story very briefly sure someone I know
used to compete at the collegiate level
in marathons and they're telling me a
really funny story about one particular
marathon that they ran back in the day
the National meet was held out in the
American Southwest and so this person
was like they had to do it really early
right to try to beat the heat and make
sure that people weren't gonna just like
die from heat exhaustion so they did it
early and apparently they they timed it
at a time that coincides with all the
snakes like Oh coming out of it out of
their holes Oh God so like one of the
main challenges was like can you avoid
the snakes on the route while trying to
run this marathon at Nationals so a very
intense sport especially when there are
snakes everywhere that's wild so the the
other marathon related thing for for the
five listeners who've made a marathon
science so for for the five people
who've made it this far into the episode
there was actually another marathon
record broken pretty recently which
unfortunately got overshadowed but which
I think is is almost as impressive given
the record that it beat so bridgid
Cascais ran to 1404 breaking the female
marathon record so note about that the
previous record was by paula radcliffe
which was to 1525 set all the way back
in 2003 so this was a 16 year old record
still on the books there were some
people who had gotten kind of close to
it but not within like a handful of
seconds I don't think I think there was
still kind of like a 15 30 second
cushion between that record and in the
next-best and so one you know breaking a
sixteen-year-old record is always super
impressive but then too she beat it by
over a minute
taking it down from 215 25 to to 1404 so
and that was I believe that was Ana
sanctioned event as well so I mean
Kipchoge a's incredible and he deserves
all of the praise he gets for the sub to
but III think not enough I think that
overshadowed cascais world record which
you know was done in a standard meet I'm
pretty sure it may not have been but I
think it was but you know wiping a 16
year old record off the books and doing
it by over a minute that is also
incredibly impressive and I feel like
she she deserved more attention than she
got one final note not about marathon so
much but just track and field in general
is it may surprise you to hear that
someone's breaking a sixteen-year-old
record because there is the perception
that like every sport is improving all
the time and people are constantly
setting records I recently posted a
video to my Facebook page of washa
hitting the heaviest clean-and-jerk ever
caught on camera and a couple people in
the comments were like dude like total
is only improved like eight kilos since
the 1980s like that's kind of sad bro
and it's like one like testing was
completely different back then
insofar as until wada formed in like 99
the Olympics were essentially untested
not completely but like not any
we're close to what is going on today so
you know any improvement at all in the
super heavyweight weightlifting record
in a sport that is obviously very
strongly influenced by drugs like sure
people are still on but they they at
least have to be drug-free on the
platform with if that urine sample which
very much did not used to be the case so
one that's impressive in its own right
and then to the assumption that there's
you know tremendous amounts of progress
being made in every sport that's just
not the case so during that conversation
I went through and just checked
Wikipedia to see what track and field
records were on the books and when were
they set and between both men and
women's competition there's something
like thirty thirty one records from the
90s or before still on the books a lot
of them in like power sports so like
throwing and whatnot or like shorter
distance races largely because like with
with changes in drug testing it's it's
made it in some sports very difficult
for modern-day athletes to compete with
records that were set under a very
different anti-doping regimen which I
feel one I think that that makes New
World Records more impressive to a
degree that I think a lot of people
don't quite fully realize you know
because if you go into it with the
assumption that Oh Rex in every sport
are falling all the time it is
impressive but you kind of expect it to
happen that's really not the case like
people currently setting records in a
lot of these sports again are probably
using that can't get away with using as
much as people used to be able to so
when they do break those old records I
feel like that makes it even more
impressive and yeah just you know I felt
like I was going to say two things about
that and then only one came to mind oh
yeah really sports aren't progressing a
lot of them at the rate I think a lot of
people perceive and so Bridget cascais
wiping out a 16 year old record
incredibly impressive but also shouldn't
be taken as that surprising because
there's a lot more 16 year old records
on the books and I think a lot of people
realize sounds good
any any non marathon related feats of
strength this week yes so actual feats
of strength easy I mean I wouldn't
consider a marathon a feat of strength I
said on the front end a feat of athletic
performance ok fair enough
so us APO Nationals were we're pretty
pretty recent I kind of expected that
I'd have a lot more World Records from
Nationals to discuss but yes seemed like
seemed like in a lot of weight classes
just kind of a pretty rough competition
all around some people came in not quite
at their best dealing with illnesses or
injuries
I think judging was quite strict which
which made it more of a challenge for
some lifters but there were still
several records set and quite a few
notable performances so first off got to
give a shout-out to my boy Bryce Lewis
totaled nineteen eighty nine point six
pounds or nine oh two point five kilos
at 1:05 that breaks we're Vicki's world
record in the 105 kilo class which is
awesome I think Bryce has previously
held that record before but for a while
we're Vicki was kind of looking
untouchable there for a little bit and
so in Bryce Bryce I think prior to this
had his best total in 2017 and then was
still really really good through 2018
but kind of not rising to his old peaks
and so like you know obviously a super
competitive lifter but honestly this
total surprised me a little bit
so this was this was awesome to see
Bryce is a great dude glad he took the
record back so next another world record
from Samantha Calhoun she totaled eleven
hundred and twenty six point five pounds
or five hundred and eleven kilos in the
63-kilo class so world record obviously
very very impressive she's been making
considerable progress over the last few
years and I only see her stranglehold on
that class continuing and then a very
very noteworthy performance this this I
think was my favorite story out of
Nationals so if you've been following
just like lifting facebook or lifting
Instagram for the past year or so you
have probably seen mahalia Reeves even
if you don't like even if you don't know
the name you've probably seen videos of
her so she's a 15 year old girl the
first video of her that kind of went
viral I think she was benching 330 and
since then she's competed in a few meets
put up either 365 or 370 on the platform
in the bench press again it's a 15 year
old girl which you know blew minds and
so she qualified for nationals
still lost to Bonita Brown because
everyone loses to Bonita brown because
she's a monster but she she tied for
second in the total lost on body weight
so she got a bronze medal but tied for
second place on the total with thirteen
hundred and fifty point three pounds I
forgot to get the kilos for that but
that's a little over 600 kilos I believe
but that so it was the second-best in
nationals and it's tied for the third
best drug-free female total of all time
which is wild cuz again let me reiterate
she's 15 years old so everyone knew
she had a huge bench she's posted a
bunch of videos of that people have seen
it on the platform before I was pretty
surprised with the squat
so she's posted squad videos and a lot
of so the ones I had seen were box
squats that looked to my eye a bit high
and so I was like well you know what's
it gonna be when she actually has to
sink it and take the box away she still
squatted something like 525 or 540 or
something like that which is outrageous
and she also deadlift at 4:40 so that's
just wild she's incredibly strong her
future in the sport is super bright
definitely a rising star in the USA PL
and just powerlifting in general I don't
know how old beneath is but one if she
ever decides to retire from competition
it it looks like the future of the
American super heavyweight women is is
pretty safe and then last but not least
got to give a shout-out to Jamar Royster
we've talked about him on the podcast
before I said he was gearing up for a
big squat at nationals
I don't know that he got quite as much
as he wanted to get he squatted 305
kilos which is - which is 672 so that
ties him for the second biggest squatter
in that weight class of all time and his
total moved him into the top 10 of all
time in the 83 kilo class so I don't
think he hit quite the numbers he had in
mind but still had a very good meet PR
total top 10 of all time so congrats to
Jamar okay before we move on there's one
more feat of strength that must be
mentioned so feats of strength we've
previously talked about American
football players on one occasion when we
we acknowledged Wisconsin's offensive
line they came off a great game and they
deserved it but this weekend
Ohio State faced that very same
offensive line
Oh state has a defensive lineman named
chase young and he was an absolute
problem chase Young had six tackles five
for a loss he had four sacks force two
fumbles and I believe both of those
fumbles turned into touchdowns going the
other way so chase young if you watch
the game stats aside he was just a
genuine nightmare for everyone involved
even the plays he didn't make the tackle
he was just everywhere all at once
absolutely incredible I mean he's the
most dominant defensive player in
college football since endemic ensue
that back in his should have been
Heisman season yeah and so that's where
a lot of people went with it right after
this game
people said chase young you have to put
him on the Heisman shortlist defensive
players usually don't get a lot of love
in recent years for the Heisman so we'll
see we'll see where that goes but in any
case he was an absolute problem just
absolutely insane athleticism and keep
an eye out for him in coming weeks very
fun to watch okay so for the next
segment I don't know if we have a name
for this one it's a media review media
review contemporary cinema so views of
the week exactly yes so at least a
couple listeners there's a new
documentary out it's called the game
changers and at least a few visit
listeners messaged me and said hey you
should listen to this and then talk
about it on the podcast and I want to
possibly put Greg through that I did not
ask him to view it but I went ahead and
fell on the sword and watched it myself
and I've got some opinions now let me
state my biases on the front end I'm an
omnivore and normally when someone does
something nutritionally that I think is
potentially ill-advised or unnecessary
I usually just mind my own business I
don't particularly care but it's when
you or when they
begin to start telling other people how
they should be eating
or even worse start masquerading as some
type of distributor of science that
that's when I start to take a closer
look at it and in some cases get a
little bit annoyed so the game-changers
documentary it's basically it's like a
very Pro plant-based kind of Pro
vegetarian Pro vegan type documentary
and it follows the main protagonist
who's basically like an MMA fighter who
is like also like a self-defense
instructor has a knee injury starts
reading a bunch of research and comes
across this paper indicating that
gladiators had high bone mineral density
and probably mostly ate plants so you
would think that you're laid up and the
years I don't know when it was filmed
2017-2018 you'd think you'd be looking
at the contemporary nutrition literature
for nutrition guidance but instead we
went to the archaeology literature and
went right to the Roman gladiator era
now the idea that you're gonna make all
your nutrition decisions based on the
bone mineral density of gladiators with
archaeological evidence there are at
least one or two very small holes in
that theory hey Greg you you were
telling me some very interesting things
about gladiators that I had not yet
heard yeah they kind of wanted
bodybuilders to be you know II mean
gladiators yeah yeah gladiators they
wanted gladiators to be like a little
bit fat because like so when people
think gladiators they probably think of
the movie Gladiator where a lot of
people are dying in the arena but for
the most part like that's not how the
vast majority of gladiatorial contests
went they were like some died obviously
but they were somewhat akin to like
famous athletes of the era and so if
there's like a popular gladiator last
thing you want them to do is like get
killed in a in a meaningless match but
you know the
[Music]
the audience still wants to see a show
they want to see some blood and so they
wanted them to be hefty enough that over
the course of a fight like fighting with
somewhat dull blades they could get cut
up and bleed a little bit and it seemed
like super intense and dangerous but
without the like without as much risk of
them dying so that that was based on
what I've read about gladiators that was
like the Romans the Romans were somewhat
of the opinion of like a lot of people
currently where it's like oh if he like
obviously bred was a huge part of their
diet but the idea being if you eat too
much starch you're gonna get fat and so
they were like yes feed them all of the
starch make them kind of fat so they can
they can bleed for the people in that
that at least is what I have read about
why the the gladiators diets were what
they were yeah but I mean the thing that
kills me is like I've done DEXA scans on
a pretty large number of retired
professional football players American
football and the one thing I can tell
you is that most of them have pretty
high bone mineral density and you can
see that in the research literature as
well but that is not indicating that you
should therefore model your diet off of
what they're eating because like most of
them were like yeah I don't really work
out anymore and I eat a lot of fried
food when I feel like it like they had
high bone real dense mineral density
because they were large athletic people
who had been loading the hell out of
their skeleton for decades and ate
enough like they did not have inadequate
nutrition one of the like introductory
points they made was that Nate Diaz beat
Conor McGregor in a fight because eating
animal products makes you worse at
fighting the logic they're not
particularly tight or rigorous in my
opinion but they went with it and that
was kind of one of the jumping off
points for the whole the whole ordeal
with this documentary so yeah the whole
premise of it starts there
and then goes on and kind of follow
several different trajectories related
to the the the typical arguments you see
in favor for for vegan diets some common
themes this is not just them but like
any time you watch a nutrition
documentary there's going to be some
pretty heavy cherry-picking of you know
we're gonna discuss this research but
we're not going to discuss that research
we're gonna have very Pro vegan guests
that we interview but no one to present
like the opposite side of that so
there's plenty of that throughout
there's a lot of deriving nutrition
evidence from sources that were not
nutrition interventions they it was like
a lot of like little demonstrations with
like two or three people it was a lot of
a tremendous amount of anecdote and that
kind of stuff there were a lot of really
wild false dichotomies that were
presented and and there was also a total
disregard for the idea of like
dose-response relationships and any
distinction between risk and relative
risk and so what I mean is that they
kind of treated it as this false
dichotomy of like you're either going to
eat like a vegan diet or you're going to
eat like literally the worst
interpretation of like a super high fat
processed meat Western diet with a ton
of sugars and starches too like there
there was really not a lot of discussion
of like okay what if you had a mostly
plant-based diet with a little bit of
these particular protein sources it kind
of set things up most of the questions
that it attempted to addressed were
either-or type situations where in a lot
of times or in a lot of those instances
there was plenty of room for nuance and
they kind of treated animal products as
a categorical variable you know you're
either vegan or you're not you're either
a vegetarian or it or in omnivore and so
they would almost in certain in certain
places in the documentary treat the
addition of any type of animal source
protein as if it was like a categorical
thing that official
that meal essentially ruined from a
nutritional perspective or or went from
being a healthful meal to now a
deleterious unhealthy meal that does
harm and so this is not unique to this
particular documentary like if you've
been in the game a while the new
nutrition documentary comes it comes
along it's the same thing just you know
put whatever label you want on it there
were a couple weird points that they put
a lot of effort into proving that
probably didn't need to be proved so one
was that humans are not carnivores I'm
on board with that okay that makes sense
to me so they showed you know like a
diagram of a jaw and they're like does
that look like a carnivore to you and I
was like nope so well I mean some
esteemed sources say otherwise correct
well we add stronger by science we teach
the controversy which is that there's
there's two sides of that story they've
they went really hard on the whole like
okay let me ask you this cows have more
muscle than a human but cows don't eat
meat how do you explain that one and
that's a hmm
I can't tell you the last time I had a
pain in my second stomach you know like
it just makes apps it's like it's like
if someone was like you know I heard
that circadian rhythms weren't important
important for health but how come
raccoons are awake all night like well
because they're not they're not people
they have their own rhythm like yeah in
in so to be clear for anyone wondering
about rumen and physiology they have a
bunch of bacteria in their hindgut that
bacteria breaks down proteins and
particularly cellulose and the plants
that they eat and then they regurgitate
that and then swallow it into like the
stomach that's associated with their
digestive tract and so they largely
derive their
their protein from both the amino acids
from the proteins broken down by the
plants actually I lied they do have
bacteria to break down cellulose not a
protein but they they do have bacteria
that break down the other proteins and
the plants but one of the main places
they get protein from is the actual
bacteria from their hindgut
that they then swallow there's
apparently a pretty reasonable amount of
protein in that so like ultimately cows
do end up deriving considerably more
usable protein from the plants that they
consume largely via the bacteria then
humans would be able to derive from
consuming the exact same plant stuffs
they didn't really go into that part
yeah I'm just trying to provide value
for the listener yeah so for some reason
that was not a high priority on their
list of points to make one of the points
that they spent a lot of time trying to
reinforce also counts as another one of
their false dichotomies and you know for
some reason they felt really intent on
proving that protein is not a key energy
substrate during high-intensity exercise
regardless of what kind of diet you eat
I don't know anyone that has pushed that
idea within the last like probably fifty
to a hundred years but in any case they
spent a lot of time trying to really
reinforce this idea that you know
athletes all think that you need animal
proteins to fuel your exercise but in
reality you need carbohydrates first of
all like I said I don't think really
anybody in the contemporary sporting
world it really believes that that you
need proteins whether they're from
plants or animals as a key energy
substrate and for high-intensity
exercise and more importantly it kind of
created this weird dichotomy where it's
like you you're either going to have a
high carb diet or you're going to have a
diet that includes some amount of animal
products or animal proteins and it's
it's a dichotomy that just has
absolutely no basis and again it's
trying to refute this idea like I don't
know who out there
is thinking that their key predominant
energy substrate for high for
high-intensity exercise work is animal
protein but that's not the case and the
the whole discussion surrounding that
weird dichotomy just made no sense to me
because I eat generally speaking a
pretty high carb diet with all sorts of
animal proteins all throughout it so
it's just a lot of wasted effort that
didn't make a lot of sense a couple
other things they did they they did a
bunch of these like little mini
experiments basically just showing that
the postprandial effects of different
meals were different I didn't find them
to be particularly informative and they
also like really had a disregard for the
idea of protein quality and while I
understand like listen if you have a
reasonably you know diverse a diverse
diet that is getting amino acids from
several different sources and you're
eating generally enough yeah you're
probably not going to be clinically
deficient in any particular amino acid
most likely but but they kind of like
throughout the entire concept of protein
quality is like a just completely not
useful concept whatsoever and in sport
nutrition that's that's just not what
what the evidence would indicate like
maybe that particular claim wasn't
supposed to relate to sport necessarily
and was just like hey you won't die of a
horrible deficiency but when your
documentary is kind of athlete after
athlete after athlete it lends itself to
saying you have to be able to apply
these these claims to sport if you're
going to put a huge percentage of your
documentary together around athletes who
use this diet for you know potential
performance or recovery benefits a
couple lowlights there is an absolutely
tragic scene with a leg press I don't
even want to talk about it right I don't
want to talk about it I mean you should
be clear with the people it wasn't a
tragedy insofar as like the leg press
tragedies that have been caught on video
or someone hyperextends their leg and
there
lower body explodes is more just like a
horrendously poorly performed leg press
a forehead touched to knees that's all
I'm gonna say so that what that was a
low way uh-huh
like I said there were some experiments
that were like that there was a way to
do experiments there's a whole field
dedicated to it you want to do nutrition
experiments go do nutrition experiments
but there are these weird demonstrations
that they presented as if they were like
rigorous scientific evidence which was
just like yeah no thanks they invoked a
lot of scary imagery toward the end
about like the you know the various
trade organizations that promote protein
intake very explicitly compared them to
tobacco companies trying to muddy the
research waters with with misinformation
and then linked that to making sure that
they were feeding like plenty of sick
people to the big scary pharmaceutical
industry so that was a low light for me
there was also a urologist on who's
spent a pretty large amount of time like
really gleefully talking about nocturnal
erections like nighttime erections that
you get while you're sleeping and they
did this like experiment thing with with
three people it didn't really make a lot
of sense because I I don't know who is
making their major dietary decisions
based on the frequency or relative
rigidity of their nighttime erections
while they sleep it just doesn't seem
like a key consideration when it comes
to putting together an overall diet but
they spent a pretty significant amount
of time on that and the whole experiment
they did was just strange it didn't
really make sense and I don't see a
great deal of relevance for why that
experiment should have any indication as
to whether or not I decide to eat animal
products it just seemed to be fairly
irrelevant and a very basic
demonstration of the fact that there are
some things in the diet that can acutely
affect or impair blood flow nothing very
revolutionary there so conclusions
after watching this you know it was like
every Doc Nutrition documentary pretty
much ever there is a way to progress the
science as it pertains to nutrition it's
not through rivaling documentaries so
you're not gonna walk away from it with
any remarkable revelations and the
paradigm for how we understand nutrition
has in fact not been shifted now I've
said a lot of dismissive things about
the documentary itself those should not
be interpreted as dismissive things
about plant-based diets or even vegan
diets you can absolutely put together a
very well formulated vegan diet if you
are on a vegan diet for religious
purposes for ethical purposes whatever
the case may be
I fully support that and there's
absolutely nothing wrong with being on a
vegan diet it can be you can be on a
remarkably healthful vegan diet that
absolutely fully supports your athletic
endeavors so being dismissive of a
documentary is not the same as being
dismissive of plant-based diets in
general and so if you want to walk away
with this with some kind of informative
final take on the state the state of
nutrition after this documentary was
shared with the world it's pretty much
the same and I think if your focus is on
living a nice healthy productive life
as it pertains to making your nutrition
choices well we still know generally
speaking what some safe bets are be
active maintain your body composition in
a relatively healthy state of leanness
scale your calorie intake to your
activity levels so that you're not
consistently overeating eat a whole
bunch of vegetables and fiber like
vegetables are awesome for you so that
that is one of the things that you know
one of the good things about this
documentary is it it highlighted many
many good things about vegetables which
are unequivocally awesome you still
don't want to eat a bunch of like
torched burnt charred fatty processed
meats that's still not a great idea as
we've discussed previously
you know if you kind of twisted my arm
and you said Eric you need to tell me
like what what - you make sense as a
sensible diet and it's gotta be one of
the diets that has a name I think that I
probably lean most towards something
resembling like a Mediterranean type
diet you know I'm not saying like it's
the end-all be-all for diets but if you
were to ask me like hey Eric what makes
sense for dieting I'd say well eat a
whole bunch of different vegetables that
tend to be pretty fibrous that give you
a bunch of micronutrients get some nice
get some nice grain products in the mix
as long as you don't have any underlying
health issues that would preclude it a
little bit of fruit in the mix with
plenty of fiber you know get some nice
fish get some some protein sources in
the mix you're good to go I don't know
why that's such a controversial take I
don't I don't know why we got to keep
doing this thing where it's like you
should either only eat steak or you
should only eat lettuce you can put
together a diet many different ways and
make it work
plants are still awesome but you know
that this documentary in terms of
providing a compelling argument that is
robust to counter arguments it falls
short
so my final review everybody knows you
always review review a movie on a scale
of one to five bags of popcorn in this
case I'm going to give it two bags of
popcorn covered in margarine the second
bag comes because Arnold is in it and
you have to give Arnold a bag of popcorn
so you go from the bare minimum one bag
of popcorn up to now two bags of popcorn
the production quality was also good I
got to give him that I think it was
produced by James Cameron so you can
think of this as the Terminator - of
nutrition documentaries interesting
story about Terminator 2
Arnold's performance in Terminator 2 was
so compelling that one of my family
members was brought to tears by the
excellent dramatic work so Arnold got
absolutely snubbed should have gotten
the Oscar for it but in any case very
very wonderful
I thought Terminator 2 was considerably
more enjoyable than the game-changers
the production quality the nuts and
bolts of the audio and video was quite
good the robust nature of the argument
presented not super great one thing to
keep in mind also when you think of like
well there's the studies saying that
like vegans live way longer than an
omnivorous when you look at the studies
that actually try to really deal with a
big problem in that literature which is
the presence of other health-related
behaviors so like if you've made the
decision to go vegan you've made a
health decision that requires pretty
pretty big buy-in on the front end and
so one way that people study is like
just compare vegans to like any random
omnivore who also like smokes and hasn't
exercised in seven years but when you
compare people who went vegan for health
related reasons to people who are
generally health-conscious omnivores
those differences in lifespan and in
chronic disease risk essentially
disappear so like that that's one other
thing in the documentary they went
really they really really leaned into
this idea that like if you go vegan
you're gonna live way longer
of course you a vegan can be a very very
sensible way to design your diet
assuming that you you know put it
together effectively and you get all you
know get your amino acids sorted out you
get your b12 sorted out and all that
stuff but the idea that it's like an
immediate life extender compared to a
very well-constructed omnivorous diet
doesn't really hold up with the
literature so because Arnold's in it we
have two bags of popcorn and to appease
the filmmakers we're gonna cover that in
margarine rather than butter big deal
if you are interested in you know trying
out a vegan diet or a plant-based diet
if you aren't currently a vegan or
vegetarian or if you're a vegan or
vegetarian and you want to know how you
could improve or optimize your diet for
athletic performance we do have a guest
article on stronger
by science about that published last
year title is plant gains advice to
vegetarian and vegan athletes it's quite
good it got shared in like one of the
vegan Fitness subreddits and by and
large they were like whoa these are
really high protein recommendations
otherwise great article so it it has
like half of a like vegan Fitness
community's seal of approval I think
it's quite good work and so yeah we can
link that in the show notes so if you
are interested in setting up like more
of an evidence-based vegetarian or vegan
diet check out that article I think
you'll get a fair amount out of it yeah
and like so you know the other day I
told you like I'm officially dieting not
for a show but I was like yeah I need to
get leaner the first thing I do and I'm
like it's time to get leaner I trend
toward leaner protein sources and I
increase my vegetable intake
dramatically so it's not like I'm some
like you know veggie hater or I think
that you need to eat like a super meat
heavy diet or anything like that
but it's just like dude you can do vegan
and make like a solid evidence-based
case for vegan diets like that that's a
thing you could do and that's a thing
that if that's what they did I'd be like
oh wow thank you for informing the
public it probably wouldn't have been as
entertaining for anybody like that's why
whenever you're like hey how come all
the documentaries are like really
dramatic and rarely just have a bunch of
scientists and then like the nocturnal
erections guy yeah yeah I mean it was
yeah it's a really good nutrition
documentary would be like a few really
solid really solid nutrition researchers
around a table say hey let's try to find
some common ground here we'll clearly
delineate the areas where we have
disagreement and then we'll put it all
together at the end no one's interested
that's not going to be fun you're
right about that yeah okay for our next
segment Greg is going to share a
research roundup about some recent
studies related to training yeah so
there's been a lot of cool stuff that's
been published recently so first paper
that I would like to briefly discuss is
titled acute effects of foam rolling on
range of motion in healthy adults a
systematic review and multi-level
meta-analysis by Wilk and colleagues and
so basically what they were doing in
this meta is they wanted to compare the
acute effects of foam rolling on range
of motion compared to a nothing and then
B - static stretching so for the studies
that included both a foam rolling and a
static stretching condition and so
basically what they found is that foam
rolling is unsurprisingly better than
nothing reasonably large effect size
kind of if you use the standard Cohen's
cutoff it was right between a medium and
a large effect at 0.7 for
however foam rolling and stretching had
essentially the same effect size so the
the standardized mean difference there
was point o2 which is nothing so none of
that should really surprise anyone I
feel like a few years ago people were
way way more aboard the foam rolling
train and way way more anti stretching
you know there were a lot of people who
went so far as to say like oh like acute
stretching will slightly improve stretch
tolerance but will like barely affect
range of motion but foam rolling has
been sent by the gods and is the best
thing and it's gonna tremendously
improve your acute mobility and you know
you know it seems like both of them are
effective and similarly effective so
that's cool just a decent thing to note
I kind of think the actionable thing for
this study is you know if you like foam
rolling foam roll if you prefer
stretching stretch both of them if you
overdo it it can decrease acute force
output and perform
if you do like a moderate amount of
either of them it's probably gonna be
fine so yeah if you need to work on
range of motion before training pick
which one you like do it it'll be fine
one interesting thing about this study
is they look to see if there are any
significant moderators and one of the
things they found both when comparing
foam rolling to nothing and then
comparing foam rolling to stretching is
it seemed like the impact of foam
rolling was larger for females than
males
so when comparing foam rolling to
nothing the acute effect on range of
motion the standardized mean difference
was 0.95 for women which is a pretty
large effect and point three five for
men which is a pretty small effect and
then I don't remember right off the top
of my head what it was with stretching
but it was something like point like a
standardized mean difference of 0.3 in
favor of foam rolling for females at
about point four in favor of static
stretching over foam rolling for males
the the authors had a line that was just
like the reasons for this remain to be
elucidated or something like that like
basically they didn't even throw out a
hypothesis for why that would be the
case I've been stewing over this I can't
come up with a good reason why foam
rolling wouldn't be as effective in men
but it's worth noting that they found it
both for like the isolated effects of
foam rolling and foam rolling compared
to static stretching and it wasn't like
you know it wasn't like a subgroup
analysis where there were like three
studies looking at it I want to say you
know there wasn't a huge body of
literature I think there were 20
I think 26 studies in total included in
this meta-analysis and there were I
think eight in the like sub sample where
you could where you could compare men
and women in the in the effects of foam
rolling so it seems to be like a
somewhat robust and reliable finding
I can't think of a good reason why that
would be the case is anything coming to
mind for you Trek's no not at all not at
all
all right so yeah do with that what you
will foam rolling generally seems to
work
possibly works better in females why is
why is that who knows I tell you what I
much prefer it that way though like it
it can go a couple different ways like
sometimes you observe a thing that you
can't explain first and you're like well
I guess we'll have to try to see if we
keep observing this and then try to
figure it out from there but you know it
that beats the alternative is which is
when people like theorized that their
way into thinking there's some like
really important distinction in some
kind of training or nutrition outcome
and like the data just like never
supports it but they're like no it has
to be this way because of this like
physiology theory yeah from like
textbook knowledge and like yes
sometimes people go so far with
theorizing without ever confirming that
it's something we observe in real life
so uh but it is I mean very surprising
very unexpected so it'll be interesting
if people in that area of research kind
of see that paper and say well let's
dive into this thing and design a couple
studies yeah yeah for sure I mean yeah I
have no idea why that would be the case
but yeah it would it would be pretty
cool if like future research could
elucidate a mechanism there because yeah
I mean it could very well be that if for
whatever reason you're trying to
maximize range of motion either acutely
or increases in range motion chronically
it could very well be that the the best
approach to that differs based on sex I
don't know that we currently have
research to like research giving us
physiological mechanisms to explain why
that would be the case but if that did
turn out to be the case you know maybe
this is kind of our first inkling that
that that is something to look into
further
all right moving on to the next study
this is by Mauro and colleagues title is
low skeletal muscle Kapler ization
limits muscle adaptations to resist
since training and older adults so what
they did is they took a relatively small
sample 19 total subjects 10 males and 9
females and had them do a whole body
resistance training program for 12 weeks
and what they did is they they divided
them based on capillary density and so
they had like retro actively they had a
group of people with low capillary
density and a group of people with high
capillary density and what they found is
that both capillary density was like
significantly associated in terms of
like you know just a straight-up
correlation with muscle hypertrophy
after resistance training and they also
found that like on a group level the
people who they defined as having a
higher capillary density did experience
significant hypertrophy whereas the
group of people with low capillary
density did not and so this was this was
an interesting study because it was
essentially a replication there was a
study for maybe two or three years ago
by Snyder's and colleagues that found
essentially the same thing and so one
I'm a sucker for a good replication
I don't think replications get as much
love as they deserve but they're
absolutely fundamental to the scientific
process and then to I think that so this
study kind of feeds into one of my pet
theories for what limits hypertrophy so
I think this is something we've talked
about on the podcast before but we we
talk a lot about you know practical ways
to to maximize muscle growth or what
research says about like oh does this
level of volume cause more growth than
this level of volume or like dis
periodization have an impact blah blah
blah whatever but we very rarely sit
down and ask the question like why do we
stop growing in the first place because
you know you start training you get
bigger
train for longer you keep getting bigger
but at a slightly slower rate and then
eventually like I mean it seems like
virtually everyone eventually just hits
a plateau past which either they just
can't grow or maybe they're still
growing but it's such a slow rate
it's basically imperceptible and so the
question is like why does that happen
and I don't think we currently have a
good explanation as to why so you know
the the most basic thing that's going on
when your muscles are getting bigger
smaller is just muscle protein balance
we don't see the muscle protein
breakdown really ramps up as people get
more well trained and we don't have that
much muscle protein synthesis data after
training on on people with a fair amount
of training experience but what we do
have indicates that yeah like the total
muscle protein synthesis ponds in terms
of like area under the curve for 72
hours post training isn't as big for
trained lifters as it is for untrained
lifters but it's like half as big but
certainly people who've been training
for 10 years aren't growing at half the
rate as people who've been training for
two months so like yeah it's it's a
weird question like why do we eventually
stop growing and my hypothesis is that
it might just purely have to do with
oxygen delivery and I think that people
I don't know I think people sleep on
just like the importance of geometry in
respiration so eukaryotic cells are way
bigger than oh god the word slit yeah
periodic cells in one of the primary
reasons why or the primary reason why is
mitochondria so essentially you need a
membrane across which for like the
electron flow to take place to
synthesize ATP and prokaryotes do that
across their cell membrane and so you
wind up with a surface area to volume
ratio problem I promise you didn't come
into this podcast
expecting to hear about marathons and
geometry and respiration but it's
happening just deal with it
so prokaryotic cells are reasonably
small because it's a surface area to
volume ratio problem as a cell gets
bigger volume increases faster than
surface area if if the surface area is
largely what determines the maximal rate
of respiration then as the cell gets
bigger and bigger it can't produce
enough energy to power these stuff
inside the cell so that keeps
prokaryotic cells reasonably small
eukaryotic cells on the other hand have
internal mitochondria those mitochondria
can have a lot of like membrane surface
area then you can have a bunch of
mitochondria inside a cell to allow the
cell to make you know a bunch of ATP and
keep getting bigger and bigger and
bigger so that that's one of the primary
reasons why eukaryotic cells can be so
much larger than prokaryotic cells but
ultimately it still comes down to oxygen
delivery and ATP production and so if
you have more muscle capitalization you
have more capillaries in contact with
each muscle fiber and so they can
deliver more oxygen to the muscle fibers
themselves but as the fibers get larger
like let's say you have four capillaries
in contact with a single muscle fiber if
that muscle fiber gets larger then one
like you know per unit of area inside
the fiber the amount of oxygen that can
be delivered goes down and then also
like stuff in the middle of the muscle
fiber is now a further distance from
those capillaries so the diffusion
distance from the outside of the cell
just takes a greater distance and more
time for oxygen to diffuse to the middle
of the cell where a bunch of stuff is
and so I'm of the opinion that there
there is least an argument to be made
that one of the things that ultimately
limits total muscle growth is total
fiber size and one of the things that
limits total fiber size is just the
ability to get
enough oxygen to those fibers so you
know I'll note this study in the older
Snider study both performed in older
adults so you know take that for what it
is but I do think that there's I do
think that there's a theoretical reason
to expect that eventually a single
muscle fiber can get too large for it to
really make sense for it to keep growing
unless like capillaries per fiber goes
up so it can get more oxygen to it and I
think there has to be some theoretical
limit for how large fibers can kind of
allow themselves to get just because
those just because those diffusion
distances for oxygen and carbon dioxide
keep going up as well and one other
thing I'll note is there's there aren't
a ton of studies but there are a handful
of studies looking at muscle fiber size
of trained lifters compared to untrained
lifters finding obviously trained
lifters have larger muscle fibers than
untrained lifters but then they train
the untrained lifters for a number of
months I want to say one of the main
papers here was MacDougall 1982 87
something like that had people trained
for six months and at that point in time
the previously untrained lifters muscle
fibers were at that point the same size
as folks who've been training for like
10 12 years and so then that opens up
the question like why do some people
wind up so much bigger than others do
they just wind up with a lot more fibers
and their total fiber size winds up
winds up being you know the same as
everyone else's but they just had way
more to begin with or that potentially
opens the door for maybe hyperplasia is
taking place and that's another very
contentious topic but anyway I feel like
I've gotten considerably off-topic but
but I think we just need to think more
about why would eventually why would
people eventually stop growing and I
think that just just gas exchange and
respiration is is likely to be a big
factor of that and so this is another
paper finding that people with greater
capillary
city respond better to hypertrophic
training than people with lower
capillary density so this is still kind
of like a somewhat half-baked and not
fully fleshed out idea but I I don't
know I think it's worth at least
considering it's also really interesting
that whatever the reason muscles always
stop growing when you hit a fat free
mass index of 25 which is pretty cool
physiologically I don't think we know
why yet but 25 is in fact the number
that I read on the Internet
you know someone's gonna clip that and
and you will see that brought up in an
argument on ironically it's something I
know I didn't mean I didn't mean it I
did have a question for you though yo so
what you've talked about in terms of
capillary density do you think that's
actionable like do you think that at
certain levels of muscularity it would
make sense to try to pursue methods of
enhancing capillarity to to further
promote hypertrophy down the road so
that would certainly be an implication
and I think that that is it's something
that would be a pain in the ass
to test but would be testable so for
example we see in we see in untrained
lifters that higher load and lower load
training tend to cause relatively
similar hypertrophy however one thing
that I would be interested in seen is if
you could recruit a sample of people who
were plateaued and you verified that
they were plateaued like say having a
eight-week lead-in where you have people
do you know a decent program of moderate
load training and then if if people do
grow your say you say like oh no you
were just training like a [ __ ]
beforehand you weren't actually
plateaued get the [ __ ] out of my study
but then the people who actually don't
grow and you're like okay there's you
think you're plateaued we trained you
pretty well for a while you do very much
seem to be plateaued now let's like put
you through a phase where we do try to
increase capillary density maybe by like
high rep training with with short rest
intervals should theoretically increase
capillary density and just like give it
a shot dog and see if that helps those
people grow a little bit more I don't
know that it would but that that would
be a way that you could test it so you
know maybe like Lolo training not a
great idea like not not better than
conventional training for most people
but potentially a way to get past
plateau and keep making some progress
for people who are already quite
advanced I mean that that's a
possibility and it's it's at least a
testable hypothesis yeah
all right so the next study I'm gonna
look at is by barreto at all the title
is protective effect conferred by
isometric preconditioning against slow
and fast philosophy eccentric exercise
induced muscle damage whoo that's a
mouthful anyway so what they did in this
study is they they took untrained
lifters and had them do so they had four
groups of untrained lifters one of the
groups did like fast speed eccentric
training another group did slower speed
eccentric training another group did
fast speed eccentric training 48 hours
after isometric training and then a
third group did slow speed eccentric
training 48 hours after isometric
training so too fast eccentric groups
too slow eccentric groups two groups
that didn't do isometric preconditioning
two groups that did do isometric
preconditioning and so they were they
were interested in a number of outcomes
but I think the ones that were probably
the most useful and relevant is they
were looking at voluntary concentric
contraction peak torque so basically
just like force output strength and then
they also looked at subjective
assessments of soreness and so what they
found is that in general it was a little
bit harder to recover from the fast
speed eccentric than the slow speedy
Centrex but the
ice the isometric preconditioning prior
to both fast and slow speedy Centrex led
to faster recovery of maximal torque and
also smaller increases in muscle
soreness and quicker amelioration of
muscle soreness so the isometric
preconditioning they did was like ten
sets of a three-second maximal isometric
contraction with 45 seconds between
contractions so you know something that
would take what a grand total of like
eight minutes give or take and so you
know it should be noted the subjects in
this study were untrained however I
think that this is still useful for some
of our listeners so for example if you
know let's say you've been dealing with
a bum knee and you haven't squatted for
a while and haven't done much hard lower
body training first time you get back
under the bar and really get after it
doing some squats or deadlifts or
whatever you're probably gonna be pretty
wrecked the next day that could
negatively impact your training the rest
of the week you know make it a little
bit harder to ease back into training so
something you could do is your first
session back just do some isometric
training and from the looks of it in
this paper it doesn't have to be super
super intense isometric training so you
know ten ten bouts of three seconds
really pushing hard not not gonna be all
that difficult and then you know if you
train two days after that it seems like
you know you are probably still gonna be
quite sore and you are probably going to
still have sizeable decrements and force
output for 24-48 hours post training but
the the isometric preconditioning helps
ameliorate a lot of that considerably so
you can probably apply that to your own
training if you have a layoff for
whatever reason be that for injury just
you know losing your motivation for a
while whatever going on vacation and
also if you're a trainer and you train
untrained lifters this is something you
could apply to your
coaching practice so I I think a lot of
us have probably had this experience
before new lifter walks in the door you
put them through a little assessment you
get an idea of their goals draw up a
training program for them first day you
don't want to kill them
but you know you want to challenge them
a little bit and then you get a text
message the next day or you know you see
them a couple days later and they're not
happy with you you warn them they were
probably going to be sore but they are
just earth-shatteringly sore I think a
lot of us who've been training for a
decade forget how god-awful we felt
after our first ever training session
but man it can be rough so you know it
may not be a bad idea to do you know do
that assessment and then whatever
exercises you plan to do in their actual
first training session you know that
first day in the gym just have them do
some isometrics and tell them like hey
this will help you you know maybe start
developing a mind muscle connection you
can feel these muscles that are supposed
to be contracting nothing's moving
that's gonna help you feel this
contraction a little bit better so you
could sell it to them that way and then
in their first real workout they do
they're probably gonna be a little bit
less sore and a little bit less pissed
off at you and I'll note that this so
this study used isometrics there have
been other studies in the past that have
used like standard dynamic training and
it very much seems like it's a pretty
good idea for again like a first session
after a layoff or someone's first
session in the gym period seems to be a
pretty good idea to take that session
pretty easy
again three-second isometrics here I
think some other research has used like
doglike sets at 10:00 at like 30 40
percent 1rm so like really easy stuff
finding that you know after that you're
considerably less sore after your first
real workout so the the collection of
adaptations that helps you know protect
against decrements and performance and
sore
this after training are collectively
known as the repeated bout effect or the
repeated bouts effect and it seems like
you know eccentric exercise helps a lot
with that training volume is going to
help kind of accrue more of those
adaptations but like just to kick off
the process and get some of those
adaptations rolling to really get some
some protective benefits in your next
like real workout it seems like you
really really don't need much at all so
you know pretty low intensity training
maybe some isometrics shouldn't be too
sore worn down from that and then you
shouldn't be as sore and worn down from
your next real session following that
makes sense to me all right in the final
study I want to look at today the title
is the Association of resistance
training with mortality a systematic
review and meta-analysis I don't
particularly want to attempt to
pronounce the first author's name so I
will say the senior authors name is
Lopez Jimenez and colleagues oh speaking
of which a listener sent us something to
help us learn how to pronounce things
yeah he did and man that seemed like a
lot of work yeah we're gonna get around
to using that eventually I don't think
it's gonna help for names though will it
I mean it may or may not we have to look
into it yeah listener thank you for
sending that it was very
passive-aggressive so in a way shame on
you for sending that but also thank you
for sending that we will get around to
it very soon maybe okay so yeah so this
was a systematic review and
meta-analysis looking at whether or not
and then the degree to which resistance
training decreased mortality risk
mortality beam dying and so they scanned
1,400 and 30 studies they wound up
finding 11 than that their inclusion
criteria
the mean follow-up was 8.8 five years so
unfortunately when something shows a 20%
decrease in mortality risk that doesn't
mean that you then only have an 80%
chance of dying and in fact a 20% chance
of living forever would be cool if that
was the case but it's like okay what are
the odds that you die in the next nine
years since that was the mean follow-up
so anyway they were looking at the
degree to which resistance training
throughout a lifespan decreased
mortality risk and then whether adding
additional aerobic training would
decrease mortality risk further and so
TL DR version is yeah resistance
training is good reduced mortality risk
by about 21 percent on average
confidence interval there is from about
9% to 31% which seems like a big
confidence interval but wasn't that
close to crossing hazards ratio of 1 so
it was like solidly statistically
significant 21% reduction pretty solid
however when you add aerobic training
into the mix as well so you're doing
resistance training and aerobic exercise
that basically doubles the protective
effect so it reduced the the the hazards
ratio for mortality from 21 percent to
40 percent which is good so yeah
resistance training makes you less
likely to die over the next nine years
which is good and do some cardio as well
you will be twice as unlikely to die
which is even better
so yeah the this was this was a good
paper I think I think a lot of the
medical profession has really come
around on resistance training in recent
years I know it wasn't that long ago
that like you know there was research
saying hey
cardio is good resistance training is
also good but your doctor would like
only tell you to ever do cardio and
would kind of give the side-eye to
resistance training I think that a lot
of I think for a lot of medical
practitioners that's kind of shifting
and they are recognizing the benefits of
resistance training more and more but if
not you know if you if you have a doctor
who is combative and says you should run
lifting is dumb may not be a bad idea to
send them this paper and say hey running
is good but so is lifting what if I did
both anyway so cool study I would say
it's kind of making me feel like I
should make a bold claim so what I'm
thinking is what I'm thinking is you
write a book right and you say listen so
running with a wrote aerobic +
resistance that's reducing mortality by
what 40% yeah and then according to some
interesting cinematic literature I
reviewed let's say going vegan reduces
about like 60% yeah so now we're talking
100% reduction and then we do a graphic
design where I'm on a beach in like a
beach towel and there's just a bold
claim on the cover of the book I just
wrote and it says like how to make sure
you definitely won't die in the next
nine years that'd be sick that would be
a nice book very tasteful graphic design
very good font it combinations and we
could probably do in a couple weeks
sure yeah we'll get our best people on
that okay now to play us out so I posted
an Instagram post the other day if you
want to follow me on instagram to send
hate mail my handles at Trexler fitness
because I just realized we kind of like
we took a swipe at a vegan documentary
and like a pro carnivore book and then
our our interview is about keto which
explains a couple limitations of keto so
basically like we're done we're done
we're gonna get a everyone's upset and
people over the last two episodes have
had to deal with us talking about
prokaryotes
and Bayesian statistics so we're just
it's just gonna be all hate mail from
here on out but anyway I posted an
Instagram post about I mean we UNAC
Liara get a considerable amount of hate
mail for this episode yeah and as you
guys know usually that's the type of
thing that temporary guests would handle
so go ahead and send all that to Greg
and not me as the permanent a singular
host I usually don't deal with that kind
of stuff so send all that to Greg but
anyway so I made an Instagram post about
I'm kind of coming back from a back
injury I hurt my back wrestling a
million years ago every now and then I a
great it because I'm impatient and
stupid and so I posted about it and then
the the PT we just hired on our coaching
staff Jason kind of jokingly
sent me an email he's like dude you
can't always be hurt it's kind of making
me look bad but anyway he was like
joking around cuz like it's an old
wrestling injury it comes and goes by
the way I should be very clear here
I am NOT currently nor have I ever been
under the treatment of Jason he is not
at all responsible for my general state
of disrepair at the moment
Jason's very good at what he does but I
am very stubborn and I don't take advice
from anybody and I also don't make time
to actually fix my problems I just
ignore them until they're no longer my
top priority problem so Jason was joking
around like dude you can't always be
hurt this makes me look bad let me
reassure the entire world if I actually
had the patience to actually talk to
Jason and do what he tells me I'd
probably be in a much better spot but
I'm stubborn I am the stereotypical old
man that doesn't listen to doctors or
smart people or really anybody else but
in any case we finally I finally at
least had some degree of conversation
with Jason about the general premise of
me being in pain and he he dropped a
really great line that I wanted to share
with everybody because I thought it was
so useful and it was just one of those
statements that in it's not
groundbreaking in terms of the actual
but it's such a simple nice way to put
it if you're listening now and you
haven't heard our interview with Michael
ray we got a lot of really positive
feedback on that interview really
fascinating stuff about kind of a more
modern updated way of viewing pain
science specifically as it pertains to
training but Jason and I kind of
continue that conversation and he left
me with a quote that I thought was like
a really perfect way to wrap it up in a
singular sentence like if you were
listening to that conversation you're
like yeah but can you boil it down to a
sentence and I'm gonna read it so I
don't mess it up I thought it was just
too good of a quote to leave it in my
email inbox and not share it with people
and so basically what he said was it's
important to remember that sensitivity
doesn't mean harm and so as I'm coming
back from this injury obviously you know
hey if you're a practitioner stay in
your scope of practice if you need
medical help go get medical help there's
the disclaimer but what I'm using to
kind of guide me back and I'm sure a lot
of people are in similar situations
coming back from you know an aggravation
or even a new injury it's this idea of
viewing pain as it's useful feedback but
within that biopsychosocial model there
are many inputs that influence it and
it's good to use that feedback but we
shouldn't be necessarily afraid of
movement assuming that we're doing it in
a smart way and working back in in a
fairly intelligent manner so I just
thought that was a super good quote for
people who are like how do I convey this
to people or how do I turn this into
like an applicable like really
actionable summary statement I thought
that was awesome and I think the reason
it resonated with me was because it's
kind of the way I view dieting to an
extent so like a lot of times you know I
don't know anything about injury so you
know I claim no expertise in that area
but when it comes to dieting I know a
thing or two and I often work with
people who want to lose fat and the
thing I always tell them like just like
that you know sensitivity doesn't mean
harm I tell a lot of times people fear
hunger when they're dieting the way that
someone coming back from a knee
jury fears pain and a lot of times
people when they start to perceive any
semblance of hunger they're like well
that's it from here on out throughout
the process we are going to be miserable
and hungers this horrible thing that
needs to be avoided at all costs and
when it's present were screwed and
sometimes when people are doing like
really ambitious diets that involve
getting really really lean or losing
really large amounts of weight one of
the most positive things you can do is
say we're not going to take some kind of
fearful approach to hunger we're not
going to try to avoid it as if it's this
thing that is you know inherently
remarkably problematic this is a piece
of feedback we'll use it we'll work
around it it'll be part of the process
but but yeah I just thought that was a
really solid quote to kind of wrap up a
lot of the things we talked about with
with Michael Ray so if you haven't
listened to that interview it's honestly
I'd say probably one of the better ones
we've done Michael shared a ton of
really cool information that might help
you might help some of your clients okay
so to finish off this episode we've got
another fantastic interview this one is
with a different Michael this one is
with Michael hull who works over at
examined comm and they fairly recently
put out a big what would you call it is
it an e-book or a guide
I think either would be appropriate a
guide in the form of an e-book about Kia
genic diets very very solid you know
very evidence-based and really doesn't
come come from the perspective of trying
to sell you on it or try to bash you or
try to bash the diet it basically is is
right down the middle
unbiased evidence-based of you know what
keto could be good for what it doesn't
seem to be good for and essentially
everything you'd want to know about it
so we are really lucky we got Michael
hull on the line and talked to him and
basically hit him with all our questions
about the ketogenic diet what it could
be good for who might want to skip out
on it so really fantastic interview and
it'll start on the other end of the
music
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast today Greg and I are joined by
Michael hull from examined comm Michael
thanks for coming by
thanks for having me guys so Michael you
are working an exam accom that is your
your your primary gig right now your
only gig so what exactly is it that you
do it examine so I'm one of the senior
researchers over at examined comm says I
think my fourth or fifth year with these
guys but my primary primary
responsibility is updating the
supplement guides it's one of our few
products that we have that helps guide
people on what supplements to look at or
what supplements to not look at for
specific health endpoints sleep exercise
the full gamut early and so how did you
get involved with the exam and what's
your your academic background so I did
my undergraduate degree at George Mason
University I did my undergrad in
exercise science with a minor and
nutrition and I just completed my
master's degree and a nutritional
science at McGill University
I actually got scooped up by Kamal back
when I was an undergraduate as I started
working for them as an intern he just
happened to see one of my blog posts he
liked it we reached out we connected and
here we are four years later is that is
that blog still active yeah I haven't I
don't really update it that much because
exam it takes up a lot of my time but
yeah my my original blog is still up and
kicking out there on the internet very
cool what's the name of it though it's
called nutrition as I know it calm and
the blog post he ended up reaching
reaching out to me about was a review of
the whole xxx diet oh that was nose I
yeah I remembered that website and that
article and that's why oh you were the
person behind it that's me I'm the man
behind the curtain
nice that was that was good work it
doesn't surprise me if you put that out
as an undergrad it really doesn't
surprise me that they reached out to you
about it this does great things for my
ego I appreciate that
excellent so do you want to end the
interview you want to keep pushing
forward yeah
no I think we've peaked like we're good
we can just stop yeah might as well know
the reason we brought you in we wanted
to talk you talk to you a little bit
today about the ketogenic diet I
understand examine calm the the you have
a new keto related is it an e-book
that's company that's coming out yeah
essentially it's a it's just uh it's a
big 250 page guide it just came out this
week it was called the evidence-based
keto your no hype guide to the ketogenic
diet and honestly it was just born out
of talking to our readers and our
followers and asking them like what was
on their mind what was their most
burning questions that they wanted
answered and resoundingly came back that
there was a ton of interest still in the
ketogenic diet and I think a lot of it
just stems from confusion over the
ketogenic diet so for the past couple
months we've been slogging through the
research trying to distill things down
to their practical concepts and that's
culminated in this huge 250 page guide
to the ketogenic diet and you said that
became available this week we're
recording right now
September 18th 2019 by the time this
goes up it might be like 2021 2022 but
just to give people a little timestamp
on that so by the time you're hearing
this the it is available and so who all
was was involved in the writing process
here just about everybody I mean we had
three core researchers and writers then
we had a handful of other reviewers that
would come in and then we had a copy
writers and copy editors that came in
after that to try to get this thing as
dialed in as possible so pretty much
everybody had the team had their hands
on it at one point or another we had to
pull in a couple of experts as well when
we couldn't agree on things to kind of
get through some of the heavier research
over the research was a little bit
complicated but yeah it was really a
huge team effort on our part it's
basically what I mean we've been doing
nothing but this keto grad for the past
couple months now it's been kind of this
nice all-consuming project if you don't
mind us giving or if you don't mind
giving us kind of a look behind the
scenes
what were some of the biggest things
when writing this guide that you guys
disagreed with and had to hammer out
there was a point in the I believe it
was the endurance section where we were
discussing the methods which the studies
were actually using to assess endurance
performance and which type of assessment
should we give the most occurrence so a
little bit of background on that would
just would be so the there's a question
of are the types of endurance tests
being run actually in the in these
studies actually translating to like
real world scenarios gotcha
and we actually brought in we just we
honestly couldn't decide and we got
stuck so we just brought in an expert on
on that front to help us just kind of
get through the research because there
was just so much and it was so deep at
that point you know we were kind of
hitting the limits of our knowledge base
and so I was just more practical to
bring in a an expert at that point he
kind of helped us kind of tease apart
some of the complicated nuances that we
were running into for that question no I
got you that that makes a lot of sense
yeah that was some that was that was
like a 13,000 word discussion before we
like just punted and we're like why
don't we just bring in an expert on this
that makes sense now the ketogenic diet
tends to be a pretty divisive topic as
far as nutrition goes people that aren't
into fitness are like how could a
nutrition topic be divisive but keto
finds a way so I would've met and then
in for people in the nutrition area if a
topic isn't divisive you're like this is
doing it wrong yeah this this is odd
like I'm sure that means this is what's
going to cause a big blow up within the
next 12 months because it's eerily quiet
yep exactly so I'm sure that's why a lot
of your a lot of your readers when you
kind of put out the feelers and said
what do you guys want to hear about I
think that's probably why a lot of
people said we've got an appetite for
some keto related content was anyone in
the writing
and in the writing room for examined do
you have anyone involved that is like
extremely pro keto I wouldn't say
there's anybody that's extremely Pro
keto or even against keto I mean our
whole MO is kind of just we really try
not to tell people what to do we try to
just give them the information they
might need to make those informed
decisions for themselves but as part of
the keto guide everybody actually wrote
down in the beginning of the guide their
personal experiences with a ketogenic
diet and even among the four or five
people that actually wrote down their
experiences it's a wildly different
experiences even between those five
people so we've all definitely like
dabbled a bit and keto or experimented
with it or tried it out for various like
outcomes but nobody currently is on the
ketogenic diet to my knowledge yes sorry
that's our CEO I guess yeah I think it's
important that that you guys at least
had some kind of first-hand experience
with it I think it is a really a really
informative thing to do if you're gonna
write about keto to at least give it a
shot and see what kind of challenges you
run into what what benefits you observe
before we talk too much about your
personal experience with it I do want to
go over keto in general you guys put all
this information really detailed
information into the guide but I'm sure
our listeners would like to at least get
kind of a general overview of what you
guys found as you looked into this
research so before we get too too far
into the details how do you define a
ketogenic diet so the most basic
definition is just a ketogenic diet is
literally just a diet that produces
ketones and the way you can achieve this
is primarily just through limiting your
carb intakes kind of the the general
number that's out there on the Internet
is about less than 50 grams of carbs per
day they're still going to be a little
bit of individual variability in that
but if somebody is looking to do a
ketogenic diet that's the first step
that they're gonna need to take is to
look at their carb intake and get it
down to a sufficiently low level and I
guess before they even make that
decision there's got to be some kind of
perceived benefit to making
pretty I would say pretty drastic change
to a modifying a typical standard diet
so what are the potential benefits of
adopting a ketogenic diet so there are
some of the more well-known ones the
probably the most well known one is for
epilepsy which is probably not going to
apply to a ton of people but it has been
used as a medical intervention therapy
to help reduce seizure incidents and
epileptics since I think 1911 was when
it first kind of started to gain
traction today it's more commonly used
in people with epilepsy who are also
resistant to drug management so the
other major benefit people probably look
to is weight loss and then diabetes
management or probably the other two
more widely applicable topics that
people try to or the people might be
inclined to use a ketogenic diet for and
don't get me wrong I think they can both
work for either of these conditions like
you can see a good deal of weight loss
when you go on a keto diet you can see
improvements and diabetes management
when you go on a ketogenic diet so we
kind of strove for and the guide was
saying hey like these are your options
but also consider what you're not doing
your opportunity cost here before you
dive headfirst into this it is a pretty
rigorous diet I mean just from like
personal experience like there is a lot
of you have to pay a lot more attention
to your diet than you would otherwise
so yeah like people can certainly see
broad health benefits in weight loss and
diabetes categories primarily but it
also like to your point earlier it's
important that people kind of pause for
a moment and consider like what is it
that I'm going to be changing in my
lifestyle to actually accommodate this
diet
yeah and full disclosure I've done a
pretty extended stretch of ketogenic
diet in myself about about 6 or 7 months
I mentioned it on the show previously so
I've got a little bit of experience with
it and it's it's different you know it's
not like you know it's a pretty
pretty sizable change to your eating
habits if you're eating a typical kind
of you know Western diet I guess you'd
say now you mentioned earlier I think
you said like the general cutoff people
throw around is like 50 grams of carbs a
day was that the number you threw out
there yeah
is that a universal number for everybody
is there a lot of variability there
there's a fair amount of variability
there I mean even in the studies that
are gracious enough to give us the
individual data we do see a range in
there and that's even the same with the
ketone blood cutoff so to be
quote-unquote in ketosis your ketone
level in your blood is supposed to be
around 0.5 or higher but even there
there's going to be a wide variability
so somebody could be eating you know 50
grams of carbs and barely have any
ketones in their blood and have to drop
it down to 30 or 20 grams of carbs per
day or somebody else might be eating 80
you know or even possibly up to a
hundred if they're targeting their
carbon take around exercise sessions and
they might be over a one millimole per
liter of ketones in their blood so
there's going to be a wide variety of
responses even within these kind of
general numbers that we're throwing out
and one of the things that you hear a
lot about when you when you look at
people doing keto online and they're
talking about putting their diet
together a lot of argument and debate
about how much protein can really fit in
the ketogenic diet because certainly if
you have excessive or you know if your
protein intake gets too high that can
effectively kick you out of ketosis
right so this is actually one of the
more surprising things that we kind of
discovered and and doing this because I
think like a lot of people I was under
the impression that a higher protein
intake might not take you out of ketosis
but it might reduce the amount of
ketones in your blood so it might reduce
ketogenesis if you're approaching an
intake starts to creep up too high so we
extracted data from 19 studies that
actually track
both blood ketones and protein intake
and we had to her statisticians run
through a couple of different models and
we really couldn't find any concrete
association with blood ketone levels and
protein intakes so on a very general
level it does look like higher protein
intake might reduce ketogenesis but the
extent is really super super variable
even within the data that we were
looking at it was really I mean it was
truly all over the place I mean we had
people with protein intakes of 1.3 grams
per day who are at a blood ketone level
of 0.33 millimoles and other people at
protein intake of 2.1 grams per day who
were at 1.8 millimoles so and that
proteins in grams per kilogram body mass
yeah yep grams for pili I'm a body mass
so I think even here there's gonna be a
huge individual response I know that an
epileptic ketogenic diets that they do
monitor protein intake because I believe
well with the with an epileptic it's
very important that they keep their
blood ketone levels above a certain
level so I know there and practice
people do have reduced protein intakes
as well but I think it's probably just
gonna be a matter of if this is
something that's of concern for you if
you're somebody who wants to have a high
ketone level you're just gonna have to
do a little bit of testing you know
start with like a low protein intake
actually measure your blood ketone
levels and then ramp it up over time and
see if it's actually affecting you
personally because right now the
averages are are just too desperate to
kind of give any practical advice on
what you know gram per kilogram of body
weight protein intake might reduce
ketogenesis and if I'm a person who's
trying keto and I want to if I want to
do some experimentation with my protein
intake how do I know if I'm in a state
of ketosis so if you're looking to
actually truly measure your blood ketone
levels there's three ways to do it
objectively you can measure it in blood
with a meter there are now these pretty
nifty
breath monitors that you can just
breathe into and there's the
tried-and-true urine strips their blood
ketone measurements are probably give
you the most accurate measure with
breath brain ii and the urine tests
giving you not an indication of what's
immediately happening in your body but
way of what might have happened a couple
hours ago where the blood measure is
gonna give you the most immediate up to
the information about what's going on in
your body like in the moment so if
you're looking to see how your protein
intake might affect key of genesis or
even your carbon take if you want to
mess around with how many grams of carbs
you can get away with in a day before
your ketone levels start to drop you
would probably need to go with blood for
the best more most accurate measurements
but you can probably get away with the
urine test strips if you're not inclined
to gone by the meter and the blood test
strips for the ketones because they tend
to be pretty expensive and what if
somebody is they're not trying to do
like a really granular a kind of
self-experimentation approach what if
they just kind of go on what they
perceive to be a keto diet and they just
want to generally know like does it seem
like I'm in keto are there any less
objective ways that a person might be
able to figure that out
yeah like less objectively some people
do get keto breath which is the acetone
the ketone acetone is when it's excreted
in your breath it can produce this odor
that's kind of been described as a nail
polish remover or slightly fruity but
this is something that doesn't tend to
stick around its might be something that
happens when you initially go on the
keto diet for the first weeks but then
it might disappear so it's kind of a
so-so somewhat objective measure
interestingly there are some people who
have said that they can subjectively
feel like when they are and ketosis
which seems like somewhat plausible but
it's also gonna vary greatly from person
to person so like you would just have to
like it if there's somebody out there
who just kind of is like moderately
interested in what they're like you know
if there are actually truly an ketosis I
would maybe just go pick up the urine
strips which are
cheap I think it like 50 for 10 bucks
normally just test it out a few times or
here and there on a more casual schedule
just as a spot check to see you know
what your body is doing before we move
on from determining if you're in ketosis
I do have one slightly technical
question it's something that's kind of
I've kicked around the idea for a while
or I've wrestled with the idea for a
while but if you read on message boards
and stuff like that people will some
people indicate that the more they were
on a ketogenic diet even without
significant changes to the diet over
time they're measured ketone levels seem
to be going down and people have talked
about whether or not that means that
maybe they are creating less ketones
because they're utilizing more fatty
acids for fuel
I've seen people indicate that they
think because they're more adapted to
metabolize ketones that they're just
clearing CLE took ketones more rapidly
from their blood is there any merit to
those two those contentions and then of
course there's also the possibility that
their adherence just slips slightly over
time sure right yeah so that's the
that's the kicker right so like is it
that they're processing ketones more
efficiently and therefore their body
isn't producing as many of them or is it
just that their adherence is dropping
over time and how do you even tease
those two apart I don't think we're
eight have any really good long-term
devar data or even moderately long-term
data on that there is some short-term
metabolic Ward studies that indicate
that once ketone levels hit a certain
threshold they kind of plateau they
don't tend to decrease but even even
then we're only talking about a month of
data the second study type that you
could look at to try to answer that
question is fasting where people are
just going on very long extended fasts
and in those date and those studies you
do see the ketone level not decrease but
even increase over time but again that
isn't exactly what people on long-term
ketogenic diets are doing so it's kind
of hard to say what's actually happening
we do see and
long term keto trials that are actually
monitoring carb intake and are doing
some sort of measurement on blood ketone
levels that we do tend to see on average
an increase in carbs over time and a
decrease and those blood ketone measures
over time so if I had to take a guess I
would say that for the majority of
people it's probably going to be that
their carb intake might be increasing
but I mean I can't I can't fully exclude
that it yeah like your body might just
be adapting better to those ketones and
you might see a drop if you're doing
this on years at a time as opposed to
like a couple of months that you might
see in some of these studies that makes
sense I do have one additional technical
question I kind of lied so when people
adopt these ketogenic diets typically
what you see is that I mean fat will
make up what 7080 percent of the
calories coming in something like that
yeah usually north of 60 so from a
theoretical perspective do you really
need to have that much fat in the diet
where's is the real I mean so like if
you were just gonna go really extreme
with it and just restrict your carbs
super hard and keep your I mean it
sounds like protein doesn't need to be
in a super tight range because you just
kind of do like a protein sparing
modified fast and still have some kind
of keto adaptation going on as long as
your carbs are low yeah I think you you
possibly could it actually be very
interesting to see a study where they
tanked the the carb intake but then they
jacked the protein intake to up to like
you know three or three grams per
kilogram of body weight our hires to see
what that would actually do to the
production of ketones but yeah like in
theory I think that's that's entirely
possible and it also gets back to what
the main goal of you going on like the
ketogenic diet is like are you like
chasing those ketones or those ketones
something that you want or is it just
the eating pattern that you know appeals
to you that you can maintain better the
ketones are kind of not as important as
the overall eating style well yeah I
could I can definitely see a scenario
where that might be the case that was
actually a really perfect transition and
your answer there you mentioned it you
know you have to consider or some
sometimes it's important to people like
what fits their eating preferences
now when we do studies like this in the
research what do attrition rates look
like I mean do people when subjects are
randomly assigned to this diet do they
tend to adhere to it and enjoy it
somewhat well well there's a there's two
components so that question once the the
dropout rate and then once the adherence
rate so the dropout rate is those people
who fully left the study they abandon it
they quit the adherence rate might be
those who are still in the study they
stick it out to the very end but whether
they were truly eating keto or not might
be kind of up for question so there is
an unpublished meta-analysis that looked
at this looked at 30 keto studies over a
thousand participants and found a
average dropout rate to be similar for
low calorie keto diets and low calorie
non keto diets so in both cases
everybody was on a like a calorie
restricted diet it was about 24% for
both groups no big difference there have
been some interesting long-term studies
that are not necessarily keto but kind
of get at this question of dropout rates
one of them was the Framingham State
food study where people were divided
into three groups
high carb moderate low carb again the
dropout rate was about the same between
the groups around 26% per group but one
of the more I think informative Studies
on this question was again not a keto
study but started off in the keto carb
range
it was the diet fits study that came out
in early 2018 that had it was huge trial
was 608 participants half a randomized
to low-carb and half a randomized to a
low-fat but one thing they did
differently than most studies is that
when they randomized 300 participants to
low-carb they actually started them out
at 20 grams of carbs per day for the
first two months of the year long trial
and they were told after this period
that you can't either
stay at this very low carb level or you
can increase your carb intake to a they
were to the minimum level that you felt
was sustainable so three months into the
study the average carb intake was
already up to around a hundred grams per
day and when you looked at the people
who are still reporting ketogenic levels
of carb intakes they were also reporting
unrealistically low calorie intake so
there was some question of the veracity
of whether they were truly like
ketogenic or not but on the whole even
when people randomly assigned to these
this initially low carb diet
nobody opted to sustain that over the
12-month trial but then you have to just
oppose that with people who might be in
a study who chose Gita or opted into
keto who might have a higher drop out
and adherence rate so let's say a person
figures out how to do a you know a solid
keto diet that works for them their
adherence is good they're loving it what
are the potential drawbacks of adopting
a ketogenic diet as kind of a long term
diet solution well it really just
depends on their individual preferences
and their individual medical
considerations one that is universally
true regardless of either of these is
you have to pay attention to your micro
nutrient intake any diet including keto
that restricts lots of foods or food
groups you're going to naturally
increase your potential risk of under
consuming vitamin and minerals and
hitting those requirements so this is
one consideration that you have to think
about when you're switching over to a
ketogenic diet is that the amount of
effort that's going to go into planning
to make sure that you are actually
hitting these things is gonna go up so
your your time requirement and your meal
prepping you're gonna have to do a
little bit more research so you might be
comfortable with or used to in order to
make sure that you're not getting
horribly deficient and in any one
vitamin or mineral you could go the
multiplied
if it's something that you don't want to
you know think about you just kind of
want to use a general band-aid to make
sure that you're hitting all your
vitamin and mineral needs but even there
you're gonna have to put in some amount
of research to make sure that you're
getting an appropriate multivitamin that
is well formulated because the formulas
for multivitamins are all over the place
so you make sure you really want to make
sure that you're getting one that's been
like well developed it's actually gonna
suit your needs as a ketogenic diet err
yeah I noticed in the in the guide that
you provided some guidance for finding a
decent multivitamin supplement but it
really seems like that might be the
route to go I mean some of the
micronutrient gaps that you guys that
identified I mean we're talking calcium
fiber iodine iron magnesium potassium
sodium vitamin A b1 b 9c d that's a lot
to supplement individual yeah I mean
certainly not you're not gonna be
deficient in every single one of those
but there is a pretty a pretty long list
of potential insufficiencies with the
diet yeah and like one thing it's
important to communicate from our end is
that we are playing the odds here right
so like when we're talking about these
nutrient deficiencies we're talking
about or not even the deficiencies but
possibly inadequacies we're talking
we're playing the averages here right
like we're looking at studies we're
seeing what on average has changed to
vitamin and mineral intakes just in
general and like here are the ones that
look like you should look out for but it
might not happen with your specific
ketogenic diet it really just depends on
how your individual diet is formulated
so it might be beneficial to track it
for a bit just to see if you are going
to be deficient and any of these but
again that's gonna take a lot of time
and effort and if you're somebody who's
just like I'm just gonna you know this
is like this is too much effort this is
getting too nerdy for me then of what
multivitamin might be a decent option
for you if you're just somebody who
wants to make sure that you're kind of
like hitting all your bases you just you
know you put in the effort at one time
to research a really good multivitamin
and then you kind of can coast on that
for the duration of your diet maybe with
some check-ins down the road yeah so
eventually in this conversation we'll
get to the good stuff we'll talk weight
loss and performance but before we
there there are a couple other things
that I I often hear about as potential
drawbacks that I'd like to get your
input on but sometimes you hear that
Kido is associated with potentially
unfavorable changes in blood lipids and
also potentially I've heard some people
say hair loss you have any any evidence
to support either of those claims so the
blood lipids we actually do have some
good data on what's what's going on
there long term so a big ketogenic diet
study the Verta health study had just
recently published their two-year
results so in this study they had about
300 individuals with diabetes on a
ketogenic diet it was a very intensive
program there was lots of monitoring
there was lots of follow-up there was
lots of support in place to make sure
that these people were actually adhering
to the ketogenic diet so at the end of
the two-year mark they did see a
sustained drop in triglycerides a
sustained small increase in high density
lipoproteins HDL and they also saw a
sustained increase in low-density
lipoproteins or LDL so there is an open
question of what this actually means in
the face of other improved biomarkers
right so these people in this study they
lost a ton of weight I think the average
weight loss was 11 kilograms and they
had a ton of other health markers
improve across the board so there's kind
of a question of well does this actually
matter like does this increase in LDL
actually matter like given what else is
happening to these people's metabolic
profiles so it this kind of also comes
down to your own personal risk threshold
right like for me I tend to be pretty
cautious so if I was on a ketogenic diet
and I did see my algae I'll go up I
would probably take measures to try to
get that down you know increase more
fibrous vegetables in my diet maybe use
a fiber supplement to help keep that LDL
or to help drop that LDL but this is
also a place in the guide where we
recommend that people go talk to their
doctor about this especially if they
have a history of heart disease or
elevated cholesterol profiles and it
doesn't hurt to get a baseline either
before you even start this diet so you
can actually have some data to track and
see what's actually happening like to
your blood lipids over time because some
people are totally fine and some people
their blood lipids across the board will
improve and it all comes down again to
that individual formulation of how you
are executing the ketogenic diet yeah
this is one of those areas where Tito is
kind of a tough sell for me because in
in the context of a fairly typical diet
I think we have a generally pretty good
idea of how our different cardio
metabolic risk factors relate to certain
aspects of diet and so like you you
could without you
I guess outside of the framework of keto
you could design a cardiovascular
oriented diet that you feel really
confident about and so for me with keto
when you get to this thing where it's
like well some of the markers look
better some don't look better what's the
net effect of that the uncertainty there
for me I think is kind of a tough sell
when you juxtapose it with more
traditional diets where I feel like
we've we don't have a perfect under
perfect understanding but we're at least
I think in the ballpark of what a
heart-healthy diet looks like yeah it's
we actually even posed this question on
like the for the thousand foot level and
one of the sections where we talk about
you know should you even go on a
ketogenic diet and it's always you know
compared to what like what else would
you be doing if you weren't on a
ketogenic diet or what else is out there
like what's your opportunity cost so we
took the example of the Mediterranean
diet right so it's a Mediterranean diet
is has way more studies out there they
have very long-term trials about the
Mediterranean diet so you have more
information about the risks and benefits
of a Mediterranean diet compared to a
ketogenic diet where there aren't as
many studies and there certainly are as
many long-term studies about what's
going on on a for your long-term health
on a keto diet so if you're somebody
whose personal risk threshold is a
little bit higher
you might be the one who opts for the
more well study the more well understood
diet such as Mediterranean style diet
but there's gonna be other people out
there who are saying you know what like
the I guess I understand the risks I
still think it's gonna be worth it for
my individual you know circumstances so
I'm still gonna give it a go so that's
really what we're trying to do with this
guide is just give people the
information they need to decide you know
what do I want to do like for myself
and hopefully they discuss it with their
health care provider or a dietician if
they need to if there are if they have
medical conditions they have to actually
take under consideration as well now on
the topic of individual differences and
preferences one thing that you one thing
that you see a lot just in the general
online discussion of ketogenic diets is
there's some people like in the key to
sphere who just [ __ ] love it you know
not just they think that it's the best
way to eat but you know they have
anecdotes like I tried this and
instantly my entire life got better my
energy levels were better my sleep was
better everything is awesome
I love this diet so much and then other
people give keto a shot and it's
literally the exact opposite story like
energy levels tanked
I'm now having sleep problems I hate
literally everything about this diet so
I mean part of some of that might just
be like psychosomatic just based on how
well they expect the diet to go going
into it but do we know do we know
anything about like physiologically are
there predictors of whether people will
take well to the ketogenic diet or not I
mean I wish that would be amazing
I not that I've seen we did dig into a
few of the that we didn't have one for
keto but there was a one trial that we
looked at that examined could genetics
predict who might be a better candidate
for weight loss on a low-carb versus a
low-fat diet not a ketogenic diet but a
low-carb diet and at least with this was
also the diet fed study at least
there are 600 participants in there and
the genes I actually looked at those
couldn't even predict who might be
better at losing the weight on a given
diet it doesn't mean to say that we
can't get there but I think it's gonna
be a lot harder than people tend to
think it might be just because of the
way that I think genetics has been kind
of sold at large is kind of this
wondrous you know like you can your
genes can tell you exactly what to do
down to like your very precise
you know regimen and I don't think we're
especially with diet we're just not
there yet there are certainly areas
within diet that we can be like like
caffeine and genetics caffeine
metabolism and genetics but with keto
response in genetics no I think that's
that's probably uh that's probably a
little far off it'll be super cool and
when it arrives
no I I feel yeah I think I think people
discovered the gene for sickle cell and
B gene for Huntington and they're like
oh [ __ ] this is easy like just find the
one thing that's a gene yeah
predict this but yeah you're you're
right like everything else is a lot more
complicated and I wouldn't expect us to
know like genetically what's going on
but I was wondering if there were just
you know other measures or biomarkers
but yeah sounds like there's not that's
actually part of the one of the kind of
unknown areas is like the long-term is
when people debate about like what is
like you don't have to adaptation that
when does it actually happen like one of
the more unknown areas is the long-term
effects of this on various hormones and
and so I mean I think that's gonna be an
open question for a while just because
that takes a lot of money to fund a
study that would actually look at that
in mass for an appreciable amount of
time no I I got you okay now one one
point to clarify
we've talked a little bit about
carbohydrate intake so thus far is it's
safe for listeners to assume that we're
talking about net carbohydrate yeah so
this is actually one of the things that
we recommend in the guide is that as
opposed to counting total carbohydrate
which would include fiber is that you
just count your net carbohydrate which
is
basically the card the total
carbohydrate content - the fiber content
I think this has a couple of advantages
primarily the first advantage would be
you're gonna get a little bit more
flexibility in what you can eat in a day
cuz you know 50 grams of carbs a day is
not a lot and you it really is an
allowance for your day and if by
counting by excluding the fiber that
you're taking in
you're gonna free up your diet a little
bit to be a little bit more lenient and
how many and what types of food you can
actually eat before you hit your
personal carb threshold for the day
whatever that might be the second
benefit is that you're actually probably
gonna get more total fiber intake doing
it this way as well
fiber intake was one of those nutrients
of concern which tends to be under
consumed on low carb or ketogenic diets
so at least from our perspective we
think it's a pretty good way to go
because you're possibly getting a little
bit more food flexibility your pasta
making a little bit more fiber and
possibly a little bit more other
nutrients by excluding that fiber from
your total carb intake yeah that makes a
lot of sense now for the listeners who
have been patiently waiting we've
hammered out all the stuff to make sure
that you would actually survive a keto
diet I think we've already pretty
objective pros and cons or you know
potential benefits potential downsides
now we're gonna get into the good stuff
so we're talking fat loss muscle
retention and performance so first
looking at the body comp side of things
I'm sure that that was a key focus of
the research you did on the diet
how does keto stack up to a more
traditional carbohydrate intake when it
comes to fat loss muscle gain or muscle
retention during fat loss yes this is
probably one of the most contentious
areas of the keto diet online at least
in the online sphere and consequentially
I think this was our longest chapter as
well I think this is like a 50 page
chapter that we dedicated just to these
topics because they're so contentious
and because the data is so mixed on this
so one of the things that we did is when
we're looking at
it's the body composition on a keto diet
is that we looked at studies with keto
with prescribed exercise and people who
were on a ketogenic diet where exercise
was not explicitly prescribed by the
authors so and the ketogenic diets that
had prescribed exercise we even limited
it to those trials that were controlled
trials where there was even exercise
prescription between groups where the
blood and urine ketones were measured so
we could have have some objective
measure of if they were actually
following the keto diet or not and they
had to have a objective assessment of
body composition such as DEXA or by
electrical impedance BIA so these were
kind of the main four things that we
looked for and we turned out 10 studies
that actually met this inclusion
criterias the last is anywhere from
about 6 to 12 weeks so pretty good in
terms of a training study there was a
couple of 1 2 3 4 5 12-week training
stays in there so it was pretty good the
trouble came and trying to figure out if
the reported measurements and fat loss
and lean mass change seen or actually
real so there's an issue with using dexa
and BIA measures on ketogenic diet airs
because when people go on a ketogenic
diet they tend to lose a lot of water
weight and the Aleut tend to lose a lot
of stored carbohydrate in the form of
glycogen and this can really mess with
these measurements these decks and
measurements whose body composition
measurements so this is actually one of
the things that we really struggled with
is like what is the practical takeaway
of the data that we're seeing in these
body composition changes given the
potential measurement error that we know
is going to be in some of these studies
so instead of kind of like drilling down
and giving you exact numbers and saying
hey like here is exactly you know how
much like fat loss or if I you might
lose or muscle you might gain on a
ketogenic diet I think the best that we
could do with the data that was there
was show you what trends that we saw in
those studies in those ketogenic diet
studies where lean mass was either
preserved or increase and where fat loss
was maximized and the results will not
be as surprising - and he listeners of
his podcast the trends that we saw were
that those who did the best on the
ketogenic diet in terms of body
composition changes or those that had
high daily protein intake seen one point
six and two point three grams per
kilogram of body weight
they had very good levels of exercise
and volume and intensities within their
prescribed exercise program and their
caloric intake levels do not create
drastic caloric deficits so as to
hopefully better preserve muscle mass so
I mean bottom line is that we just you
need more studies that take steps to
reduce the body composition measurement
errors that are introduced by these
sudden shifts and hydration status and
stored glycogen status and that is the
type of study that we would need to
actually see if on a granular level like
a ketogenic diet or how on a granular
level the ketogenic diet is affecting
these lean mass and fat mass changes
while undertaking exercise but I mean
for now the best we got our trends so
that's what we were able to report yeah
what about in comparison to a more
typical non keto diet did you see any
trend indicating that it was any more or
less favorable when it came to body
composition outcomes no not really
the ones that we extracted the tense
days that we saw were pretty they tended
to be fairly evenly matched and we even
looked at a couple of subgroups where we
thought that training status protein and
another mostly protein and training says
were evenly matched between the two
groups and even there like it was hard
to say just because of the measurement
errors that we were seeing but we did
not see huge differences between the two
so there if there is I said well this is
this is me hypothesizing right now you
know so like if there are actually
meaningful differences between the two
training modalities either training
Aikido or training on non Kido I suspect
they're probably going to be relatively
small at least for body composition all
things being equal I'm glad that you
guys didn't over interpret you know
little fluctuations in those body count
measurements you know I've done about a
billion body contests in my life and it
always kills me when somebody over
interprets a small study and says like
well the one group lost 1.5 kilos but
the other girl lost 1.8 so at least it's
leaning and that it's like no that's not
leading anywhere yeah that's that is
absolutely nothing yeah at that point 3
kilos is like 1/8 of the measurement
error yeah this is this is one of those
sections that I actually rewrote this
three different times just because we
were literally struggling to get useful
information out of it given you know the
amount of measurement error that is
probably in these results anyway I mean
and that doesn't even get into like the
differences between like you know the
errors that you could see when you're
comparing a different DEXA machine using
a different algorithm that uses
different underlying assumptions between
studies because I've I mean one of the
things that I would like to see in these
studies is that they actually report the
DEXA machine that they're using the
software version that they're using and
the algorithm that they used
because each has different underlying
assumptions that can really change the
way that we're gonna compare these
studies so like really all we were left
with at least for these types of studies
and the it was just trends and general
overall arching trends we couldn't
really drill down much more than that
because then it's just gonna get there's
too much error involved at that point
yeah
so switching gears what about when you
know a lot of times people switched
Aikido some people say it totally tanks
their performance some people say that
it just you know was a game changer now
they're performing way better what does
the research say about Kido as it
pertains to physical performance so this
was actually this is what happened to me
when I would Nike know I I was one of
the ones who did not
I was not able to recover my exercise
performance until I fully cycled off of
it even by the end of the second month I
was still feeling pretty like gassed by
the end of higher intensity workouts
overall with the data we have on
strength and again we don't have you
know the perfect study on this right
like so ideally you'd have a study that
has a keto group at a control group both
are undergoing the same exercise regimen
monitored and like prescribed by the
research staff they're getting their
meals where they're at least being
tested for blood ketones and they're
measuring strength and blood ketones at
different time points so you can measure
the change in strength in the keto group
compared to a non keto group but alas
this does not exist so we're left with a
handful of studies and perfect as they
may be to try to get at this answer so
at least on a strength or looking just
at the strength metric it does not look
like the ketogenic diets hinder or
enhance strength performance or gains
but again we're looking at a limited
number of imperfect usually short-term
studies so you can even take that with a
grain of salt so then we have to kind of
back up a little bit and look at
underlying biochemical mechanisms so my
best our best guess really is that if
you are really looking to absolutely
maximize muscle strength and muscle gain
you're probably better off on a higher
carbohydrate diet and that might even be
in the low carbohydrate range so you
might only be consuming you know 100
plus grams of carbs a day but for
everybody else where this is not like
the absolute most critical part of it
like they're gonna be fine like you're
not like severely hurting your muscle
gains you're probably not going to be
severely improving them either but if
the ketogenic diet is something that you
find works for you and works for you
well this is probably not something you
need to worry about orally at least that
most people don't need to worry about
you mentioned that when it
when it came to the cardio performance
there was a lot of back-and-forth he had
to bring in a net what what exactly was
the the source of confusion when it came
to the endurance type exercise outcomes
so an endurance studies there's usually
three ways to assess it was a street
commonly used ways to assess endurance
performance you can measure time to
completion for a set distance so if you
run the same distance in less time your
endurance performance has improved you
can measure distance covered in a set
time so if you run a little bit faster
in the same amount of time we can say
the endurance performance has improved
or we can measure time to exhaustion at
a set pace so if you run longer or run
further at a set pace your endurance has
also improved so so the debate was over
the intersection between these
measurements and the vo2 max that they
were being measured at and whether that
is an appreciable difference between
like a recreational runner versus a
professional level endurance runner
right so for this one was a little bit
more easy to actually or at least with
more confidence we can say that it does
look like a low carbohydrate diet would
impair your endurance performance at the
elite level it might not matter as much
on the recreational level just again
depending on your individual preferences
but if you are an elite athlete to where
performance absolutely matters and it is
the most important thing to you then
even a key to adaptive athlete the odds
are that it will probably not help but
again I can't conclusively say that it
might not for everyone like there might
be somebody out there who this does
actually help for their particular set
of circumstances so we were pretty
careful to kind of convey that in this
section because I don't want people
coming away with the idea that Kido
hurts all endurance performance and all
scenarios
because it just might not matter to
Pacific depending on your cinema
circumstances there might be people who
are just like hey like I enjoy going on
like really long hikes on the weekend
and I like to like day hikes and I just
like I don't want to eat so there might
be a advantage to that because like very
low intensity levels where they might be
able to keep going without feeling
hungry do we know how keto effects
lactate threshold levels it's not
something I don't think we actually
looked into that for this version oh you
know what no actually we so initially
there was a huge biochemical chapter
that we were gonna write that we ended
up probably probably saving it for the
update of this just because I got I got
super nerdy I was real nerdy and so we
were gonna reset that one on the side
for version 2 of the keto the keto guide
I got you one of the arguments that I've
heard before is that maybe keto
decreases vo2 max but increases both
relative and absolute lactate threshold
so for like really long duration stuff
it could be beneficial so I was just
wondering if if you guys had looked into
that at all so like they're really like
really long in terms of like you know
like the hundred-mile like the multiple
day-long races like that kind of event
yeah so the the exact context of this is
we mentioned keto on the podcast oh
maybe three or four weeks ago and it was
we've recorded this before Zach bitter
broke the 100 mile track world record
yeah and then the it was released after
he did that and there were a couple
people who commented on the episodes
like oh no like Zach bitter he's this
low carb runner and he just broke the
world record you guys are full of [ __ ]
well they're right do you follow
Zach bitter at all and know anything
about that I've heard the name bantered
around you know internet forums but it's
not something I followed no Greg did you
say that he he kind of takes a cyclical
approach to his low carb intakes I mean
so basically it seems like he matches
his carbohydrate intake to the amount to
the intensity of the training that he's
doing so he might be in Quito or very
close to Quito
when he's in a phase of his training
that he's doing like longer duration
lower intensity type stuff and then when
he's doing like more high intensity
training he'll eat more carbs during
those phases of training or during the
days of his training where intensity is
gonna be higher and and so I think his
like I think his total carb intake
throughout an entire year and even for
the higher intensity work that he does
is probably still lower than most
ultrarunners but it's not I don't know
in terms of like a general sense it's
not incredibly low carb at least through
most of the year and it's certainly not
keto except maybe for like the really
really like low intensity stuff so he's
doing more of a like a targeted low-carb
approach yeah pretty much okay so I want
to make sure that we have a nice little
concise summary statement here to make
sure that we were all on the same page
so it sounds like when you look at the
the keto research theoretically it can
do just as well for fat loss and
potentially even attempts at muscle gain
but there's no inherent advantage
because that's sound to be yeah on the
whole on the whole I think that's what
most people are probably gonna
experience and on the endurance front
for most endurance activities that
aren't like super ultra low intensity it
would also appear for those types of
activities that there might actually be
an impairment from Kido
is that accurate yeah the studies that
we looked at you know along the spectrum
of intensities like generally speaking
here are they're gonna see no
improvement or potential detriment just
where you are along that spectrum and
then finally for strength related
outcomes the research currently shows
that it's approximately as good but I
would contend that the higher your rep
ranges get the more likely that you
might suffer some degree of impairment
I'm not gonna put those words in your
mouth though do you do you think do you
think that's generally pretty accurate I
mean it's an entirely
possible just because looking at the
types of resistance training programs
that these people were undertaking on
the ketogenic diet for the most part
they were pretty modest so I don't know
I think there was maybe one that like
really pushed them into the higher rep
range and that is the one that did see a
link better preservation of lean mass
and stuff like that but yeah it's
entirely possible it's just this is one
of those things that you know or just
we're kind of handicapped by the
research is available to us now which
tends to be like a decently formulated
but still moderate volume resistance
training programs yeah my experience
with keto is really similar to yours
where I did it for a good six or seven
months my workouts I kind of had that
idea in my head like ah I just hang in
there surely it'll come around I tend to
do higher rep stuff generally on pretty
high-volume programs that are oriented
toward hypertrophy and my my performance
just never came around and after six or
seven months it's like hey if it ain't
here yet it's just not coming just wear
keto adapted I know it's like that I
swear if I would have like posted that
and been like this keto stuffs BS
somebody would have been like dude the
magic happens in month eight I think I
can't believe you cut bait early yeah I
mean the whole Aikido adaptation thing
is a very interesting debate and it's
one that we looked into when we were
writing this guide is because there
isn't really a well-defined you know I
cut off that everybody actually agrees
on and there's so many possible metrics
that you can look at too and there's so
many possible metrics that just haven't
been studied like the hormonal changes
over like long term so it is kind of a
you know a shoulder shrug at this point
but like maybe maybe not but they're
getting to see if and they were you know
upcoming years if people can kind of get
around a central definition of what
exactly is keto adaptation because at
this point doesn't seem like you know
everybody disagrees on you know what the
best possible metric for that is yeah in
some circles it seems to be kind of a
mythical ideal but you know I do want to
be quickly
I have really really don't have any
major issues with the keto diet in
certain context but the only thing I
ever get annoyed with is just the like
extremely overzealous people who push it
for every possible circumstance and say
like oh it's this magical kind of diet
that's hacking all these different
systems of the body and it's like it
just doesn't seem to to line up with any
evidence that we have aside from the
people who insist upon it there was
actually a ton of interest on like
topics like that like when we were
surveying our readers I mean we got
requests for you know can keto treat
Alzheimer's cancer diabetes migraines
Lou Gehrig's Parkinson's like to the
point where we literally just dedicated
an entire chapter called Ken Kido tree
Todd just to summarize the research on
all these these tons of endpoints of
people are interested in or they've
heard that hey like oh I'm you know my
you know my grandfather is doing chemo
for Alzheimer's like what's the research
so we just we wanted to make sure that
we kind of covered that as well because
I know that that is a extremely like hot
area where again there is just isn't a
lot of research so it's ripe for you
know exaggeration does it seem like he
can treat anything that would surprise
people migraines
was probably the most surprising thing
to me I again there is not a lot of
research here there is two clinical
trials I could find one was a it was a
small trial with 18 subjects and they
did see a reduced migraine frequency on
a keto diet after one month the second
study was actually more interesting to
me because the way that they set it up
it was there was a larger trial so there
was 96 females who were randomly
assigned either receive a standard low
calorie like very low calorie diet for
six months or a very low calorie
ketogenic diet for one month followed by
five months of the standard low calorie
diet so a group one is just on your
normal like calorie restricted diet
group 2 goes very low-calorie keto for
one month and then does the standard
low-calorie for the next five months but
in that one month the keto group saw a
huge drop and both migraine attack
frequency and days with headaches and it
like almost rebounded back to baseline
and when they went back to the standard
low calorie higher carb diet like both
groups overall saw reductions in
migraine so that might be some weight
loss interaction there but like in the
keto group the graph just looks like
this big check mark we're just like
plummets from the NARC you know and just
bounces all the way back up when they're
when they're on the standard higher
count or a higher carb diet so that
would be that wouldn't surprise me and
I'd definitely be interested to see if
anybody follows up on that research in
the future that's pretty wild because I
I had not heard that before and it's one
of those things where a lot of times
like headaches affect so many people
that yeah that one would think like hey
if here if there's a dietary
intervention that can do something about
this that's something that like the keto
folks would be shouting from the
rooftops like hey you guys trying to
like lose weight get better perform like
a [ __ ] caveman and not have headaches
anymore you should do this diet but it
yeah that that's weird that that's
something that's not publicized more if
if that seems like a possible benefit
yeah I think this is about maybe just
like got slipped under the radar cuz
there's literally two studies on this
but yeah if this is not something that
I've heard amongst any of the the keto
groups that frequently at least it's
really cool yeah I thought that was you
know I was super interesting because I'm
sure somebody out there with a migraine
might be saying hey you know like maybe
I will try the ketogenic diet and see
what happens so we've got definitely
certain forms of epilepsy potentially
migraines based on limited evidence were
there any other medical conditions that
you thought like you know the evidence
looks like it's at least leaning towards
some some potential I mean I would
cautiously say maybe some certain types
of brain cancers in certain
circumstances so there is
research on keto and brain cancer and at
least it seems that like brain cancer is
the area that's gained the most traction
in terms of can a ketogenic diet help as
an add-on therapy like for selected
types of brain cancers and there's a
decent amount of preclinical evidence
from cancer cells and animal models
indicating that hey like this might do
something but the research now honestly
is just one it's all over the place it's
pretty low quality and the human
evidence that we have is pretty sparse
and most of these are designed as
limited case studies or open labeled
trials that are primarily testing is
this a safe diet to put these people on
so the secondary endpoints are usually
hey did this do anything to the cancer
but right now they seem to be in the
space of we're just gonna make sure that
this doesn't that this is actually safe
for them and then it doesn't make it
worse but even in limited studies that
we have you see huge dropout rates
you're talking about 50% or higher so it
you know even if it does do something
like can you actually get these patients
to adhere to it long enough to like to
matter there was one study or there's
one a systematic review that found out
of 330 participants only 20% were even
able to adhere well to it there was tons
of complaints about fatigue dehydration
gastrointestinal upset and you know
they're dealing with a very restrictive
diet on top of everything that a cancer
diagnosis you know puts on your on your
plate to deal with and even the analyses
that were performed on tumor progression
are again like very highly mixed so like
generally speaking it seems that like
there might be something here down the
road for very specific cases but it
certainly doesn't look like to be this
like wide panacea and I bet it'll
probably end up just being highly
targeted treatment in certain scenarios
it would be my guess what if they you
know progressed these uh these studies
out yeah so this would be as good time
as any to remind the audience a lot of
people come up to me they say Eric you
seem like an oncologist
you seem like a neurologist fun
I'm actually neither and neither is Greg
and Michael are you either of those
things I am certainly not okay so if
you're listening take it with a grain of
salt talk to your doctor don't stop your
cancer treatments because you heard
Michael hull say that there was like
three low-quality studies out there
indicating some promise so yeah do that
yeah don't do that also if you have any
hate mail pertaining to keto we're gonna
put Michaels email address in the
description of this episode so you can
send all that to him I'm just gonna have
to talk to my HR about that see how this
goes if HR is Carolyn she will a hundred
percent sign off on that HR is Carolyn
and she would sign off on that that's
why we like her she's alright so
something that's been seen a lot of buzz
about this on the internet lately ketone
supplements yes I know you guys talked
touched on it in the Aikido guide so
ketone supplements are there any
applications for these so if I were if
somebody came up to me and asked me like
should I take ketone supplements for
anything I would probably tell them to
look at other more well studied
supplements first this like ketone
supplements on the whole for me kind of
fit into this like well maybe but like
you just need to wait until there's more
studies or they're able to figure out if
there's a specific area where they might
be actually applicable in terms of a
supplement research they're pretty much
in their infancy especially when it
pertains to exercise performance there's
a lot more research that could be done
so like for now it's just a big shoulder
shrug right like I probably you know
being cautious I would probably say you
know you probably want to go with the
more well still need supplements first
for whatever health endpoint you're
looking at and maybe come to these if
you're willing to do like a little bit
of experimentation but on the whole
really at least for performance benefits
it's kind of a crapshoot at this point
with most of the research indicating at
least point
- not having a substantial effect or a
positive effect at all but again you
have to take that with a grain of salt
until more more research comes out and
as little research as there isn't that
performance arena there's even less and
other health endpoints so there has been
you know studies looking at exogenous
ketones for like epilepsy like another
one from migraines but now researches is
fewer and further between and even the
performance sector so y'all just gonna
have to wait now this is surely going to
be speculate speculative on your end but
would you guess that your answer might
fluctuate a little bit for someone who
is on a traditional diet versus someone
who's been on a keto a keto diet for a
while and you know keto adapted for
whatever operational definition we have
there would you say that the supplements
might have more application for one
group than the other I mean like
possibly that's yeah that would be
highly speculative at this point yeah I
mean it might but yeah I couldn't that
would be for the the ultra experimenters
if they were really wanting to go out
onto a limb and kind of try some some
stuff out if they were already keto
adapted yeah I mean there aren't other
than gastrointestinal upset and a little
bit of nausea those two are the the main
side effects of taking too many ketones
too quickly so if there are you know
okay with those side effects and they
and they wanted to try them out sure
just as a you know as a personal and one
experiment to see if you know hey does
this actually seem to do anything for me
and like given my you know circumstances
yeah to be totally candid the premise of
my question was I'm just trying really
hard to figure out why a non keto
adapted person would supplement with
ketones I mean they they don't taste
good either has so I mean there was a
there was one study that actually has
you know I'd gone through and reported
the side effects of what people were
experiencing and so if you're if you're
one - that wants to endure the
you know bad generally bad taste maybe
some Naja made it maybe some like
stomach upset and that's you know worth
the cost benefit for you then go for it
well yeah we lay it all out for you if
if you're so inclined to do so yeah I
feel like I feel like the taste thing is
probably easy to overlook if you've
never tried them before but it's
basically like if someone's had keto
breath or you know you'd know what your
morning breath tastes like it's like how
do you feel about drinking that that's
horrible
I mean they they flavor it to like mask
it a little bit but that yeah that is
the ultimate taste that they're trying
to cover up and like it it's probably
it's still there yeah they're they're
keeping a some food scientists in
business trying to figure out how to
mask the flavor of exogenous ketones so
keido's been on the block for a while I
remember probably around 2014 there were
a ton of people talking about keto all
over the place but now there's there's a
new kid on the block and I'm talking
carnivore diet do you expect that a lot
of people who are really into the
carnivore diet have is there some kind
of intermingling between the keto world
and the carnivore world it was kind of
been interesting to see these like
trends that have happened over the past
like I would say like past 20 years or
so because it seems the progression has
been like low-carb kind of came on the
block again and then it was paleo got
hot for a while and then died down and
then keto got hot for a while I think it
probably has just hit its peak at the
end of 2018 just surely going off of
Google Trends search results keto diet
was the most googled diet last year by a
huge margin thing at the end of the year
yeah at the end of 2018 the keto diet
had something like 72% more search
traffic than the number two diet on that
list which was the Mediterranean diet
holy [ __ ]
so I think we've probably hit peak Quito
and that might start to die off over
this next year and I'm sure something
else would take it place maybe it's the
carnivore diet but it just seems that at
least in this like diet popularity cycle
it's been a push to ever extreme diets
in the low carb of the low-carb spectrum
so I don't know how popular a carnivore
diet might actually get just because as
difficult as a cute keto diet you know
seems to like me or just to most people
to try to maintain like a carnivore diet
seems like just a huge step up from that
in terms of effort and just the
restrictive nature of it which i think
is something that like I certainly
struggled with when I was doing a
ketogenic diet I fully binge daftar I
went off of my keto diet I think I
blacked out and ate an entire cake but
yeah I don't I don't know where that's
headed it's been interesting to watch it
develop online a little bit I suspect it
might kind of just be a small fierce
vocal proponents that kind of keep it
and the you know the nutrition space
consciousness but I have not seen it
break out too much outside of my
nutrition circles you know I've asked a
few random friends if they've ever heard
of this and nobody has
but everybody all of them before the
ketogenic diet so I don't know it'll be
up soon to see what happens over the
next year or so the thing I think I'm
most excited about as the carnivore diet
gets more popular I remember when keto
started getting popular and people would
start making recipes and be like this is
my Kido friendly cupcake recipe yeah I'm
interested to see what the carnivores
are gonna do in that realm the carnivore
diet desserts I'm waiting with bated
breath I'm here for like a barbecue
chicken cupcake like I'll try it out
yeah it's surely someone's gonna get
into that realm I just don't know how or
when but yeah I haven't actually I
haven't seen that either that'd be yeah
would be very just to see what actually
comes out of that there's some
metaphorical meat on the bone there if
you're an adventurous chef out there put
together a carnivore dessert put out a
cookbook see what you get how strict is
carnivore because I'm wondering where
like where sweetness would come from mmm
I guess it just doesn't or are they like
you know like the 80% carnivores like
you might be like 80% keto 20% you know
flexible kind of thing I mean if you've
if you've tried various organ meats oh I
have thymus is like slightly sweet so
it's like I'll just you know take get
some freeze-dried thymus and sprinkle it
on a steak it's basically a brownie like
I don't know like I I don't even know
how you would start making carnivore
desserts it's just it's just an idea
that I'm putting out there for free
someone can take that one with it I just
I I have had some keto desserts that
that actually were like quite good and
I've had some others that went the other
direction too oh yeah I know glycine has
a very like mildly sweet taste too so
maybe they could you know you know mix
they're mixed glycine with some water or
I don't know sprinkle it on something
who's to say but I know Greg and I
nearly got into a fistfight over the
idea of including cottage cheese in
lasagna so God knows how he would react
to any of these culinary abominations
that might be forthcoming who ended up
winning that competition by the way the
lasagna off you guys had I won it was I
was the one that made lasagna I won by
default Eric version of lasagna was
unseasoned shredded chicken breast like
marinara sauce out of a jar and cottage
cheese that was him I'm I'm here for the
simplicity of that lasagna but it wasn't
a lasagna though well first of all now
you've exposed yourself as a dishonest
charlatan because there were there were
seasonings so for you to say that it was
unseasoned chicken immediately removes
you from the competition
what were the seasonings I didn't taste
any I had what was it like was it like
one teaspoon of salt for like 47 chicken
breasts dude you wouldn't know what goes
into the subtlety of seasoning a dish
okay your idea of flavor is just to take
the nuclear option I just very had a
very subtle little pinch of Italian
seasoning a little bit of chicken broth
when I was cooking the chicken and they
really came together and I think a lot
of people had a really delightful time
eating that was on you you are you're
literally like the meme of white parents
on Thanksgiving when it comes to
seasoning food like those memes that are
every year it's like when you have white
parents and they bring out the special
seasoning for the turkey and it's just
like a glass of water that's that that
is that is your approach to seasoning
Eric you're speaking to my childhood
here oh yeah I mean it was my childhood
too
I can't I can't hate yeah okay before
Greg continues this conversation now
that's delving into race apparently let
me stop us while we're ahead
bottom line here you've got this long
detailed really informative Kido guide I
really do recommend that people check it
out we've just barely kind of grazed the
surface in this conversation today but
bottom line who is keto good for so I'm
gonna punt a little bit of that and kind
of bring up a couple of factors that
people might want to run through
themselves to see if it's a good fit for
them so though it would be preference
organization support and environment so
before you decide to like dive into this
just take stock of like what are the
foods that you like to eat like what is
your diet currently look like do you
think you might be able to maintain a
more sustainable diet by just tweaking
what you have already been doing or is
this drastic shift gonna be something
that kind of launches you into a better
eating habit overall you should consider
the organization that's gonna go into
this because you don't just fall into a
keto diet it takes a lot of diet
appropriate meals and snacks and
planning so like if you're somebody who
enjoys doing that or doesn't mind doing
that then you know this could
potentially be a fit for you if you're
somebody who struggles with that or
likes to eat out a lot that might be
something to consider before jumping
into this your support system in your
environment also matter like are your
friends and family on board do you have
groups that you can go to on
Facebook or Twitter or elsewhere that
can you can get answers from or support
from you have to consider the changes
you have to make to your home
environment you know ya consider
removing disallowed foods from your
place this might get tricky if you live
with people who are not on a keto diet
or its roommates who aren't really into
like supporting that that type of eating
habit who leave you know like Ho Hos
around there to try to sabotage your
keto diet you know so these would
probably be the four things I would
recommend somebody run through before
they kind of launch into this pretty
drastic life diet lifestyle chef because
it's not just changing your the food
that you're eating and it's really gonna
touch on other aspects of the way that
you live your life to eating out to the
way that you socialize so just be just
go into it fully informed about what
this is actually going to look like and
don't don't take it too lightly
especially have if you have medical
conditions you know go talk to your
doctor about this let them know what
you're doing like get them on board with
that and then make sure you're getting
the adequate medical tests that you
might need for your for your health
circumstances well that's a very nuanced
to answer that hard to get upset about
so really appreciate you coming by and
sharing some of this knowledge with us
about keto like I said the guide you
guys have put together is really
terrific if people want to stay in touch
with you and kind of stay up-to-date
with your work where can they find you
I'm actually most active on Twitter I
like to follow are the science Twitter
communities out there so you can just
find me my handle is at I know nutrition
so Twitter not doing the Instagram thing
no I have like four photos up there and
it's been two years yeah you know I hear
you people are very mean on Twitter
people aren't as mean to me on Instagram
I mute a lot because I just I'm just
here I'm just here for like scientists
sharing what they're doing in their labs
and like I'm just here for like
interesting science articles I'm so I
don't engage much I'm pretty quiet so
but you can find me on there if if
people want to try to reach out yeah
twitter is good for that they can also
find you at examine calm
of course awesome well thanks so much
for coming by we really really
appreciate your time yeah thank you guys
for having me thanks for listening to
the stronger by science podcast now Greg
and I are not experts in medicine or
health or really anything else for that
matter so before you make any changes to
your diet and exercise habits make sure
you check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it visit stronger by science comm to
check out the products and services that
we offer thanks for listening and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you